national master teddy coleman taking on
international master
lars oscar hogg in the i'm not gm speed
chess championship
hope you're enjoying your weekend having
a good day ready for some exciting chess
because we have that
in store for you and just a reminder to
everybody you may be new here
but you are perfectly welcome this is
the format it is a single elimination
knockout we started with 16 players now
we're into the quarterfinals
each match has the time controls you see
in front of you 75 minutes of the
longest time patrol of five
minute plus one second increment blitz
we get 45 minutes of the three plus one
finally get 25 minutes of everybody's
favorite time patrol bullet chess
and the winner moves on the loser well
they take their prize money
and they call it a fun tournament and
that prize money
you see right in front of you here we're
in the quarterfinal stage so the winner
gets 300
and moves on the rest of the price on
is split by win percentage so every
single game counts
in this format you don't want to take a
game off because that could cost you
some prize money
and let's look at the overall bracket
remind everybody how we got here where
we're going
you see that we are in the bottom
right of our bracket here teddy coleman
lars
oscar how lars beat the 2020 runner-up
elena kashlinskaya in a
very topsy-turvy day it was looking good
for alina at some points
then lars he put up great defense he was
bending but not breaking
and he was able to win by the score 15-9
and for teddy coleman against carissa
gibb that was our closest match
of the first round he wins by a single
point
there are plenty of games where look
like carissa had the upper hand teddy
fought back valiantly and he was able to
win some games
in mutual time trouble and thus move on
to the quarterfinals so we have
teddy we have lars oscar here it's going
to be
a great matchup indeed of two very
strong players
different styles and we'll see if
they'll be able to fix
the mistakes they made in their first
matches where lars some of his openings
did not go his way that's what he said
in the post-match interview
he was talking about it saying i gotta
work on my openings because alina was
just
giving me problems in every single which
way and for teddy his openings looked
very strong but there were times where
it felt like he
lost the threat of the position
sometimes the tactics were there
he played something that was slightly
wrong and he
was able to come back within the match
but it gave carissa many opportunities
and she did have so many good positions
and well this match is about to begin
we want to remind you of an upcoming
match as well because i know a lot of
you
are looking forward to that one that
will be international master levy rosman
better known as gotham chess to many of
you out there
and international master eric rosen
known as i am rosen pretty
straightforward
and that will be tuesday february 9th 6
p.m pacific time that's 9 p.m
on the east coast here and well if
you're in europe that's pretty late so i
don't know if you're going to be staying
up for that
or early in the morning i should say but
that will be a great
finish to our quarterfinals here in the
i'm not gm speed chess championship
so we have just a few minutes until the
match begins
i just saw you missed it because we put
him back on camera a second too late
there lars oscar was stretching he's
getting ready for this
intense matchup it is intense these
players they stress we saw teddy in
match one
he was there just fidgeting throughout
the whole way
and we'll see if he can calm his nerves
and play a good match against lars
because lars is here to play he is
one of the highest rated players in
terms of feed rating in the entire field
and if he can fix his opening woes that
will give his
chances a much bigger boost than uh you
know we have seen in previous matches so
lars he knows his work is cut out for
him teddy is the underdog in this match
he knows what he needs to fix and now
it's about putting all that hard work
onto the chessboard so just a minute
away
looking forward to this match beginning
here and
i don't know what else to say i kind of
want their play to do the talking
i speak a lot i've done many of these
shows but at the end of the day it's
what the players bring
and for teddy for lars oscar here
we are going to see if they have brought
their best stuff on this sunday
and i see you all welcome everybody if
you're new
this is the i'm not gm speech
championship and if you're returning you
know exactly what this is you don't need
me to inform you
of what we're doing here and we have
liftoff we do
have moves here teddy gets the white
pieces in game one you look at their
blitz ratings
it is not that big of a difference 40
rating points that's pretty close
we see d4 and c4 by teddy and look at
that a strike with c5
and we get a benko gambit so in lars
style he's sacrificing a pawn to open up
the state of the board
and you'll see that there's this tension
on a6 and b5
neither side flinching just yet because
if you take on a6 that allows black's
piece to take
right back in one turn but by playing a4
knight c3 bishop f1 you know that this
b5 pawn
is well defended so if it's captured you
can capture right back and probably with
the bishop
so you get to develop in one turn it's a
good lesson in tension here
and d6 knight f3 teddy playing this very
quickly
and the b5 capture still bishop takes b5
so
if you are going to take on b5 you might
want to wait until this bishop makes a
move because if i play bishop e2
and then have to take well black gets a
move in the process so for
lars you have to figure out what that
move should be are you going to put your
bishop on g4
and pin the knight are you going to play
with rookie 8 and try to play for e6
and said lars plays bishop to b7 which
stares into a
brick wall we see these pawn chain here
limiting the scope of that bishop but a
timely e6 can break the board open and
that bishop can actually
thrive when that move is played so
bishop e2 played by teddy
now i expect that's this capture to
happen because the bishop had to stop
and then would capture so it costs quite
a tempo
but what would still be upon the head
and of course we mentioned this move e6
we should point out every single turn
that is a possibility that lars goes for
but the problem with playing e6 is if
you capture and you capture back at some
point a knight g5
type of move will put pressure on this
pawn on e6 and teddy says
to heck with that your bishop on b7 will
not be a strong piece i'm not taking on
e6
if you take me i take back your bishop
is staring into my pawn which is well
defended by this knight on c3 so
that is the theme of this position thus
far for lars he wants to develop his
knight can't do that you drop e6 and
then d6 so
if he is going to develop the knight
it's going to only be after he settles
the tension in the center
he brings knight to a6 rather than d7 i
guess there's this
b4 square pretty juicy one for that
knight and once it gets to b4
that d5 pawn is under attack a third
time three minor pieces
going right after that pawn so we see
here that
teddy is sitting and thinking the knight
can also retreat to c7
but it's a less aggressive play so it
does attack the bishop it does attack
the pawn
but the bishop can slide back to c4 to
defend this pawn on d5 which is why
knight b4 seems to accomplish more and
right now
teddy smartly trying to figure out do i
develop my bishop out to a square like
f4 here
go after this d6 bond do i put my bishop
to g5
pinning your knight to the queen but do
i really want to take your knight with
my bishop
i don't think so this bishop on g7 is a
very powerful piece and so if you have
to capture on f6
and say the queen captures back that's a
really nice diagonal for the queen and
bishop to be
in line on so if h6 is played i think
teddy will more likely drop the bishop
back
to a score like g3 rather than trading
on f6
and knight b4 right after this pawn but
can you take it the answer for now
is no because of this pin so let's say i
make a move like rook to b1 and you try
to take
i take you take and i can take on f6 and
your queen is
under attack and so you actually can get
away with this just for the moment
because you can take mine knight and f3
but that's the kind of tactic that lars
has to be careful for is that this pawn
d5 you want to capture it so badly
but it could actually cost you some
material so queen d2 setting this exact
thing up here is now if you take i can
take back
and once you try to take on f3 guess
what there's no queen
on the d1 square so this would actually
cost black a full piece
right away so lars will not be taking on
d5 he also can't really play h6
because the queen and the bishop are
lined up on that square
so typically against the fianchetto you
want to try to trade off that bishop in
front of the black king
and here if you play h6 i steal a pawn
in the process so
that could be a worthy trade of pawns
what do you mean by trade well
h6 you give this h pawn and then you get
this d5 pawn
and that could be nice for black
especially with this bishop on b7
but that's an important pawn in front of
your king so you have to be sure about
that
before you go ahead and play move like
h6 the bad news for black you can't play
rook to e8 the bishop covers that square
so this rook is sort of stuck in place
for now so what are we going to do d5
can't be captured
at least not yet where's this rook going
rook b8 no rook c8 no not really
accomplishing all that much
so coming up with a good move here for
black isn't that easy another move i'm
thinking about is queen to a5
but if that queen comes to a5 you're
neglecting the defense of this d6 pawn
it's same deal with queen to c8
one of the ideas i have here is can i
take take and play knight to e4
coming after your bishop coming after
your pawn on d6 the bishop shore could
drop to e7 but know what you've done
you've neglected your king safety my
queen come into h6 or something like
this
could be what teddy is eyeing in this
position giving up his bishop for a
night but just trying to get after
black's pieces
so as we get back to the live board we
see teddy
over three minutes on the clock lars
oscar down to 222
lots of twos there and he is trying to
say i need to play
faster because i'm down the clock but i
also need to deal with the fact that i'm
down upon here
and he is ready at long last to take
this pawn on d5
his knight is no longer pinned to the
queen on d8 the queen has
moved out the way so this pawn can be
captured and for teddy it's now about
figuring this out do i really want to
give up my bishop on f6
well with knight e4 coming next i think
that this is a good idea
but i can understand the hesitation why
would i want to give up my piece here
this bishop could be very powerful
maybe it's best coming back at some
point to f4 this pawn on d6 is the
target if this knight moves out the way
maybe i'll get a bishop e7 if you're not
careful
do i want to play bishop c4 just to
defend this pawn right away
i'm not in love with that move bishop to
c4 it does make sense it also vacates
the b5 square for the knight to jump to
to come after this d6 pawn
but i feel like bishop takes f6 that's
where i've
set my mind on and right here teddy is
trying to figure it out himself
so now he's down under two minutes this
is it can be a problem
when you're playing blitz chess you
think that hey it's a five minute time
control
i have all these minutes here to use and
now you're
less time than your opponent you're down
30 plus seconds
and you still haven't figured out a move
in a complex position so teddy
looking at him here he looks kind of
just frozen he's
really trying to figure out the truth
this position and lars is
moving non-stop twirling his hair he's
trying to figure this out i don't think
he's happy about his position
but he should be happy about his clock
so teddy does in fact take on a six
knight to e4
as i was calling for and this pawn on d6
is a problem because if i can take that
i would be attacking your queen and your
bishop this is why lars brings his queen
back
to defend the bishop and the pawn at the
same time a very good move by lars
because he had just put his queen on c8
now he goes right back to d8 says hey
let's not worry you traded off your
bishop
and if you continue taking once this
queen takes here
d6 is not even under attack but it's
protected for good measure the queen is
lined up on this diagonal
and very importantly this pawn on d5 is
finally
falling down unless you bring your
bishop back to c4
so teddy goes in queen h6 i expect a
very quick
bishop g7 i don't want this queen in
here knight g5 is a deadly threat so
that's why the bishop
comes back and now knight takes d5 queen
takes d6 teddy's idea
you take my d pawn i take yours but this
bishop on g7
it is super strong here the pawn on b2
at the end of the diagonal
will fall in many of these lines so for
teddy
he's trying to figure this out you know
is that going to be a problem for me for
lars which pawn do i take do i take on
d5
and which piece do i take with maybe
i'll take with the bishop rather than
the knight the knight hits the queen
but we know that if the knight takes on
d5 this pawn is still under threat so
perhaps the queen
saves itself by stealing a pawn in the
process so right now lara's trying to
figure this out bishop takes d5
knight takes d6 could be the play here
and then bishop takes b2 and it gets
wild very fast i feel like black's king
is quite safe
and this pawn is valuable but white does
have this outside pawn protected by the
bishop
this kind of configuration here it's
very annoying as they protect one
another
they're just stopping the rook's
progress on the a file and later in the
game we can start thinking about pushing
this pawn
but large goes for it he takes the
bishop one d5 now the b2 pawn can
be captured so i would try to take that
he takes the knight on f3 first i like
that move
because the queen needs to stay in line
with the knight on d6 the queen would
have
preferred to take on f3 but you can't do
that with the knight hanging so
lars seeing the possibilities here we do
have the presence of opposite-colored
bishops
the bishop 1b5 remains powerful on this
diagonal
it can also just go right back to c4
going for the f7 pawn so despite the
fact
that white's pawn structure on the king
side is worse you have compromised
structure with these double iso
f bonds this f7 pawn on a light square
that could be the biggest issue on the
king side believe it or not
and queen c7 lining up a pin let's get a
rook to d8 to bishop to f8 and go after
this pin piece
and i think that's something easy to
miss you may think rook a to d8 is
coming
because you're bringing your rooks
towards the center but in fact f28 would
have allowed bishop to f8 and this
knight would have been in trouble but
now with queen of g3
that's a defended square the knight is
free to move say to e4 or c4
whoever it is safe after black attacks
the p so rook to d8 just knight to e4
and that's why lars took this pawn on b2
teddy says okay
defending my knight on d6 my queen is
free to go and i have
an open line and i will bring my next
rook to the second open line
and that way i can try to take control
of the board so lars brings his a
rook to d8 keeping an eye on the f7 pawn
but you know what this pawn later in the
game that rook is gone so this pawn can
start thinking about pushing not yet the
queen covers the square
but teddy first goes bishop c4 watch out
for the capturing f7
lara says all right go for it it's two
pieces for a rook if you take on f7
that doesn't bother me but teddy does go
for it which surprises me here
because now if the rook takes f7 there's
no way to pile up on the pin piece if
he get his rook out quickly in attack
that would be good but lars can just
biking g7
bishop takes f7 king takes back and now
it's two pieces for the rook
and this a pawn looks like it's in big
trouble and probably just being captured
so if i'm teddy
i'm thinking about sacrificing an
exchange right back maybe rook h4
and take this bishop because with the
knight
and he would be an extra pawn for white
like if you could play rook takes d4 now
there's also this nasty pin that's hard
to get out of so teddy's pushing his
pawn instead hoping to trade off some
pieces
but it looks like his king's in danger i
see the eval bar going in black's favor
here
king e4 there's rookie three checkmates
the king had to drop back and look at
this attacking pawns and threatening
forks 93 check it's a fork it wins the
game for black
and i think teddy will throw on the
tower and he does so lars takes game one
he is up one game to none after one here
and largely just he's bopping he's
feeling the rhythm
and his pieces we're doing the talking
there teddy he needs to strike back
it was a fine first game he got tactical
he didn't handle
some of that tension center well at the
key moments but
lars saw every idea that bishop takes f3
pinning the knight taking on b2
and teddy took on f7 but it was his
demise instead of black so here we have
game two underway
black has the bishop pair black has the
better pawn structure you would think
because these are double pawns
but white plays in this manner because
once you place a b3
look at the clamp and the position the
d5 square is
under white's control and black
considers sometimes play c6 and d5
himself
that way he can fight for space because
right now the pieces aren't doing all
that much
and d5 is covered four different ways by
white's pieces
so teddy on the clock right now looking
pretty calm
lars and teddy both trying to figure out
the position here knight to d7 i
really really like this move the knight
can come to c5 with a tempo against the
queen
but very importantly you're giving
yourself the option to play f5
black has a light square bishop white
does not
so if i can play f5 and actually give
this bishop some open space to work with
that is clearly to block's benefit and
f5 is not weakening the king right now
it would drop a pawn so i'm not
suggesting it at the moment
but after castling playing f5 makes a
whole lot of sense
and here white can think about casting
queen side
but one of the good things that teddy
did with bringing the knight to d7 is
he's bringing it towards the queen side
right that can come to c5 for example
and after knight c5 you might have to
take because otherwise your c4 pawn
is not defended right knight c5 your
queen moves back well actually if you
can't even go to d2 because knight takes
e4
and this pin is devastating against uh
white's queen here
so after knight c5 you'd have to take
and then i can just take back with my
bishop and say okay
i have the bishop pair against your
knights but it is a closed position
so in closed positions the knights tend
to reign supreme
and maybe you play f4 to open up the
king side something like that
but the bishop pair doesn't have the
strength
that you would prefer to and that would
require an open board state
so bishop takes knight takes c3
interesting choice there by teddy
i wonder if he felt like his bishop was
going to get in trouble if some kind of
knight d5 was the move
and then the pawn would recapture if it
was taken and the bishop was stringed
out here
but i don't really like voluntarily
giving up
that bishop it's opposite color bishops
now the pawn on c4
is defended it's hard to attack that
some more maybe some kind of a6
b5 is a way to just give up a pawn to
open up the board
but teddy said plays b6 so he's playing
against
the double pawn he's cementing that pawn
in place no c5 for you you're not
getting this kind of sacrifice or break
and instead lars goes g4 but where is
the attack going to come from you can
start pushing
all your pawns up and then black plays
g6 you'd have to play h4 h5 g5
g6 something like that but that also
feels
too time intensive you're spending all
these moves pushing your pawns
and i don't think teddy is going to just
sit and say what's lars doing by pushing
the pawns no
he's trying to attack and checking me
not going to happen so
right now teddy has a choice to make
here what
is he going for right now he's solid
black has no
real weaknesses in the position but you
want to actually do something
active here rather than just sitting and
waiting so he does knight to c5 great
that gets the piece active lars says no
i'm not going to touch that knight if i
took on c5 the b-pawn takes
thank you for the open b-file no no no
so queen to e2 he could take on c5 at
any moment the knight's not really going
anywhere
and this bishop on e6 it does stare into
the pawn
but what else queen c8 to a6 perhaps
that's an idea we see teddy go for it
the queen on a6 puts pressure on the
c4 pawn also stares down the eighth file
that scores like a3 and a2 and i said a3
first
because if the queen comes to a6 you
might play b3 but then you have to look
at the a3 squared not that it actually
gets black
in attack or much of anything but that's
where i keep my eye on is these kind of
squares on the queen side
so b3 is likely to be in white's future
but it's not necessary
just at this moment and for lars well
what do i do h4
he's giving up this pawn and that's an
interesting choice he wants to play f3
and open up the
g file so if i'm teddy i'll be very
nervous before i capture this pawn
because bishop g4 pawn f3 and white's
play next comes very obvious like bishop
e6 or let's say bishop d7 something rook
to g1
bishop h6 and just this attack feels
quite promising
for white especially in a blitz game so
i don't think that
teddy wants to grab that pawn but he
does so he says the material is
important to me
i don't mind if i do and i wonder if
this bishop can even come to h5
so you can play f5 next and you defend
actively by opening up
lines for your pieces and by playing f5
in the future your rook can come to f7
to defend this pawn
your queen can go to d7 as well so teddy
takes it
he plays bishop h5 he cannot drop his
bishop to g6 because of pawn h5
but i think he's going to play pawn five
here and as mentioned rook f7 queen d7
and everything's defended
but starts with king h8 to not even
allow bishop h6
to be played so i understand this move
it makes perfect sense to me no bishop
h6 my pawn can capture it it's no longer
pinned to a king on g8
so what do you do here for lars how do
you continue your attack do you play
queen to g2
then maybe rook to g8 and i just say hey
i'm just going to
bottle up here you're not making any
progress remember that this queen it
would like to go in
but this pawn f3 is also under attack so
the queen is doing an important job
defending this pawn f3 at this moment
and if not i think black does want to
strike with f5 this knight can come to
e6
which simultaneously defends the g7 pawn
right that's a good defensive move
but knights are tricky because they also
can just hop forward as well from e6
into d4 f4
and if you can trade off this bishop
your king starts to feel even
safer so lars has
quite a bit of extra time here teddy has
been deliberate in his approach but he
has taken upon so teddy is the material
lars has the potential attack and the
extra time
but i like black's position because i
don't quite see the concrete attacking
approach
and that can be very frustrating for a
player look to g5 does come to mind here
as a way to attack this bishop
but i guess teddy is just gonna put his
pawn on g6 and it's another reason
he put his king on h8 just to stay out
of the way so if there's a
sacrifice you take back your rook takes
over the g file first
and there's no quick checkmate because
takes takes bishop h6
if this king were on g8 your king is
really in big danger
but because the king is in the corner
you have the g8 square
for your rook to go to so king h8 was a
nice profit log to move
anticipating what was going to happen
and that's why
he teddy says i'm okay for now it's
reasonably safe
and f5 is still a defensive move that is
aggressive you play moves like this to
clear the seventh rank as i was
highlighting earlier and it gives you
quick chances to
play for an initiative against this pawn
and f3 so with 97
watch out knight f6 97 both of these
are moves after knight to d5 so you have
to be careful about that queen e6 drops
this pawn in c7 so the queen's doing
an important task so make queen d8 but
then you have to think what if the
bishop replaces the
rook on g5 that could be trouble for the
black queen and the dark square so teddy
says
you want to get to f6 not so fast i am
going to put my pawn on the square
protected by my rook and doing something
aggressive by attacking your rook
on g5 this is a great move f6 a very
calm move
in the middle of a very intense position
and this bishop on h6 it attacks the
rook takes
okay i'm gonna bring my rook up where's
your attack g7 got that covered
maybe i'll play c6 but if you play c6
this queen can slide to
g2 threading bishop g7 check ideas but
this this queen
can come to g8 so c6 is probably a move
here
it's risky i get it but this knight also
can come back to e6 i forgot about that
knight for now
and teddy says i don't want to deal with
it your knight is not actually
threatening me
at the moment c6 oh let's go back a sec
c6 would have blundered the f6 pawn
because if you take there's a check on
g7 it's clear that
this is not approved maybe just queen to
e6 or something like that and there's a
problem with the pieces here
but knight takes f6 was probably a
concern and then having an e6 does a
good job of covering the g7 square
so black bringing the pieces back and
now has more time
this is the problem with going for
attacks that you don't actually see
the clear way forward is you start
burning your own clock and then you have
to justify the material sacrifice
because black
is up a rook and a pawn for this bishop
and i get it the king is not perfectly
safe in the corner
but you don't have anything as a clear
follow-up and now you're the one
spending all your time
so teddy handles this very well he has
extra time and queen of g2 i think
intentions are pretty clear down the g
file but guess what knight
rook cover g7 no check for you queen of
rook cover g8
so there's nothing there and that's why
teddy plays queen of d7 now his rook
covers the
last rank his queen and brook cover the
seventh rank
how are you going to checkmate this
black king so 93 perhaps there's a
knight f5 i get it
but now that g7 is covered maybe knight
f4 is a reasonable move maybe knight d4
is a play and the g7 square is very
very important here and it's just
covered by too many of black's pieces
and the mod four so how can teddy
rearrange his pieces his rook would love
to be on a square like g6 or g8
sadly rooks are not queens they can't
move like that but that's what you want
it's trade off a rook
and j plays rooks e8 going to the e file
there's not much happening there
but he's allowed knight to f5 and now
this g7 square
one two three four and teddy says all
right
queen to c8 he changed the order of his
pieces this was actually
quite brilliant in fact by playing queen
d7 rookie 8 queen c8
he wants to put his rook on g8 and that
was his idea from the beginning
but his queen was in the way so he
switches the order of his heavy pieces
trying to trade off on the g file so
queen h3 i think
knight d4 is a good move now just noting
that this
queen at the end of the diagonal instead
we see a trait on g8 you can take with
either piece
bishop e3 threatening knight h6 that's a
four against your
queen and your rook this knight is now
not very well defended
queen to g6 i'm already looking at ideas
of knight takes d6 for example
trying to get this knight as it lost its
defender now
20 seconds for black 12.7 for what you
got to move here
you but you also don't want your
position to fall apart a couple moves
queen g6 is played
knight takes pawn takes you get the 96
but your king is feeling safer without
this knight on f5 so look at lars
keeping the position
as close as locks as possible rook g8
there's 97 so teddy goes in with knight
f4
he says this knight is doing well queen
g2 is a blunder because the bishop takes
f4
taking the knight which is the defender
of the queen and protecting the white's
queen at the same time
so we see it capture it d6 is a problem
he plays d5 but just take that thing
take it twice
97 probably a good move as well but i
think taking with the pawn was good
that's a past pawn now f5 teddy strikes
with the diagonal
and oh knight f6 overlooked for sure f5
is falling
this is a problem queen e7 can be played
but f4 defends and i think this is
turning in lars's favor very quickly
so queen takes h5 rook takes f6 is
probably the move that gives black some
hope
but right now black really cannot move
the pieces
so queen g5 good move rook c6 watch out
for the c2 pawn
that's the only place that can be
attacked but the queen needs to stay on
g8 the rook comes back first now queen
c7 is a possibility
queen e6 blunders main one oh missed it
queen 67 was made
that's what happens when the knight and
queen lined up on h7 and
overlooked by lars and he kind of laughs
i guess like how could i miss that move
now when the knight comes back to d5
white is still doing well 1.4 seconds
and he wins a time he wins on time and
neither player can believe it
are you kidding me are you joking and
lars is laughing he's like what just
happened and that's because lars missed
checkmate in one move
and teddy was finding these tricky
resourceful ideas
with no time on his own clock and he
actually wins the game
because lars his time elapses and that's
that it's a 1-1 match
wow that was really an electric game
there
first teddy was fending off the attack
really well then lars is still coming
for him
and yet teddy he doesn't he doesn't see
himself checkmated which he allowed
and unfortunately for lars he losing the
clock one one match at this point
and we have a dutch and this is called
the raphael variation
so we're getting the ninja turtles here
f3
i don't know what this is but e4 saying
let's just break this board open and
what's this pawn doing on a6
so in the dutch you play your pawn to f5
and we kind of have almost a stone wall
situation
but a6 that feels like a slow move
and by playing in this manner white is
able to crack
open the center of the board here and
your king is in the center sure my
king's in the center but i can go
this way and try to attack you later so
this is very weird i don't like the
inclusion of a6
it seems that it's going to be
promising for white but teddy is
thinking here probably wait this is
not what i was looking at in my
preparation either so i see the
evaluation bar says
plus 1.2 1.3 that's overestimating the
position at least from a human
standpoint teddy's not sitting here and
thinking oh i have this humongous
advantage
i like my position because instead of
this palm being on a6
maybe a move like knight c6 would have
been more useful for black but
this is where we are and e5 is tempting
taking on d5 makes sense opening the
position even more this bishop can come
to d3 have an open line to work with you
can castle this way we're going to
castle in opposite directions
and this bishop does have more
flexibility because the pawn e6 is no
longer there
but there's so many weakened squares
vulnerable squares
and these light squares there may be a
bishop here for now but if this bishop
gets traded
white puts a rook on the e file watch
out you know look at this control for
the white side here so i like teddy's
position out of the gates
and as we see here a bishop trade is
offered
and black can say i want to play queen
d7 to defend but not so fast my knight
jumps in with tempo
doesn't look very good queen c8 would
defend but then that queen's on c8 so
instead
lars brings the knight into e4 but if i
take on e7
wait a sec let's go back a quick moment
here take on e7 queen takes e7
do i have knight takes d5 knight takes
d2 no because here
captures captures that's a check to your
king
take back i'll take this one and then
finally your knight on e7 is under
attack i was just trying to take
everything and see what happened
but black ends up a piece ahead so that
would not have been good so instead we
saw a capture on e4
capture on e7 and there goes the knight
to e5
and we see a position here where black
has a bishop white has a knight
white has the better pawn structure and
in fact saying take on e5 because i will
not recapture i don't have to recapture
i would take your bishop on f5 so that's
why lars castles
and we can see a capture trait of
knights this pawn e4 is it a strength is
it a weakness
it's an isolated pawn but it's a pass
pawn and isolated pawns are bad because
they're harder to defend you want to
protect the pawn with another pawn
because when the more valuable pieces
start attacking it that way you don't
have to deal
and teddy says oh speaking of deal look
at my knights in the center here hitting
your queen
queen d6 covers the c7 square the knight
is still defended
knight back to e3 hopping around after
this bishop and where's that bishop
going it goes to e6
the e4 pawn does not feel quite as safe
so
i would probably take on d7 and maybe
consider d5 myself why not try to push
and go after this pawn take over space
bring a rook to d1 hey
that's a pass pawn for myself just like
your e4 pawn is passed but a knight is a
great blockader
so we'll see if this kind of thing
happens
lars is on the clock here trying to
figure out well where does my bishop go
can i leave it there for now he plays
knight takes e5
leaving it the knight can capture on f5
which hits the queen
but the queen can move somewhere to
attack this knight right back and
remember this pawn
on d4 is pinned so the knight on e5 is
not actually capturable
so teddy sitting and thinking he has a
choice of two
which piece are we going to take on f5
with because you cannot take on e5 you
drop your queen on d2 that would be a
big blunder
so which piece are we going to use to
take
this bishop if knight takes f5 knight f3
check would be a good idea if not for
rook takes f3
and the reason why i say knight f3 check
it blocks the rook's defense of this
knight
but after pawn takes rook takes maybe
this is okay for white if i steal your
next pawn but i don't like this open
king that
worries me for sure so i would not want
to take with the palm but you can take
with the rook
on f3 but teddy says up let me take with
the rook my knight can follow suit my
next rook can come on f1
and i'm trying to remove some of the
important pieces around your king
so your rook on f8 is more valuable in
this position
knight c4 knight g4 would be good
tactics if
the f8 rook we're not hanging with check
the reason why it will knight c4
they can just take with the knight so
let's go knight g4 i'm threatening to
checkmate you here
if you take rook takes a five that's not
good of course but the problem is
i take on f8 with check and then i take
your knights that distraction tactic
will not work out
and that's why laura's sitting and
thinking well where does my knight go
should i leave it here and take this
first but then the knight hops in this
rook follows this queen come to g5
that doesn't look so fun that looks kind
of scary for my king and my pawn
structure is worse that's an isolated
pawn
whereas white has all the pawns in a row
here everything is
nicely compact and queen d7 hitting the
knight
keeping this pawn on d4 pinned so what
next queen at
g5 rook to f1 both these moves do make
sense to me
if rook f1 maybe we'll see rook to f8
just following the rook along the
f line knight f3 check is still a
possibility after rook to f4 let's not
forget about that tactic
where i can block your defense of the
knight by sacrificing my own knight so
queen g5
does make sense but then you're leaving
this pawn on d4 that will feel a little
bit vulnerable though the knight has to
move out the way first that will give
you a tempo to play more like c3 next
so queen f4 similar idea as queen to g5
and now the knight really is under
attack this pawn e4 is under attack
and that's just the simpler move
sometimes we get in our heads we need to
be super aggressive we put our queen to
g5
but queen f4 says i'm going to win your
pawn e4
keep talking about that that's a
weakness it's isolated let me go after
it it's not defended
and now two pieces in the center are
under attack and this pawn on e4
is falling so we'll see here what can
lars do he is down nearly 20 seconds at
this point
he can make a move like knight to c6
which saves the knight but it does not
save his pawn
on e4 and by the way we should watch out
for a queen g4 move
because when we get pieces in line with
each other we could think about what
happens when the piece gets out of the
way
but of course let's take this pawn e4
first the
major downside is the rook coming to e8
taking over an open file attacking the
queen
but that's why i'm saying queen g4 is a
possibility because if these queens get
in line with one another
and there could be a discovery with a
knight hopping out the way and
the players they're feeling the pressure
right now i see them there
teddy trying to figure this out hand on
face lars sitting back but
his eyes that's all you need to know is
look at those eyes
he is really just trying to figure out
i'm down a pawn here but i should have
compensation i have an open file
this d4 pawn needs to have an eye kept
on it
so black's pieces are doing quite well
you have a rook that's developed and
here we go
what was i telling you lining this up
watch out for knight h6 check so the
king might have to come to h8 but that
costs you a move and then white can play
a move like c3 perhaps
and defend this pawn on d4 d5 is
possible
the queen will not be able to capture it
because the g7 pawn is hanging with
checkmate
but that's why king h8 was played just
getting out of the way of this discovery
knight h6
can still be played because the queen is
protected but that's not a movie you
want to play unless it comes with force
so knight to h6 not what you want so
g6 then maybe the knight comes to h6 or
to e3 to defend the queen
the point being that you cannot take my
knight because your queen is under
attack so
we have a stare down with queens my
knight comes and defends but actually
in this kind of situation you may just
get your rook into e2
and that gives black some real
compensation along the second rank here
that active rook
is nice so we'll see how lars responds
here
he is down upon so even if he trades
queens gets that rook down to e2
it may look good but are you getting
your material back is it enough
is this rook going to come to f1 and
actually do the same thing and that
would be worse because the black king is
on that side of the board
and there are plenty of checkmating nets
that you could fall into for example g6
let's say we get this position with a
queen trade rook e2
and you say okay i'm just going to go
ahead and take your pawns then my rook
gets to f7 my next move is knight f6 and
i'm going to go
checkmate you on the h7 square so that's
a mating net with the king being on h8
and you may start taking pawns good for
you well it's checkmate
because my knight covers the last square
this is not going to happen
but these things can happen especially
as we get into the bullet portion of
these bliss games right
right now right now white has a minute
and 10 seconds black has 27 seconds so
lars is down on the clock
you make a quick move that you regret
and you could actually find yourself
checking it so teddy makes a very good
decision just brings his knife back
instead of bringing the rook to f1 that
was more tactical in nature
felt unnecessary you kind of want to
keep the rooks on the board
uh so queen e7 watch out your knights
under attack rookie one
you're walking into a pin but you also
know your knight can come to c2
which defends the e1 square so queen g3
played rookie one
now makes sense from f1 if you want to
trade the rooks i'm not sure you
really want to try the works that badly
but teddy says don't mind if i do it
makes me feel safer
i don't have to worry about my king i am
up a pawn so if i can trade rooks and i
trade queens
that's the ideal situation so we see the
rook trade step one now let's see if we
get the queen trade
knight g3 knight f5 that's a good
looking idea and that e3 can come in d5
or f5
knight f5 actually threatens to win this
pawn that's why the king moved up to h7
but queen if check
okay teddy a chance to trade queens or
check and take on b7
that king on h7 is in a bad spot but so
teddy's taking up space
now knight d5 goes after this pawn here
c6
your pawn structure is cemented over
there on the queen side that leaves the
b7 pawn
as a potential target so knight e6
played defending not committing to a
pawn structure choice
now play c6 this knight should come back
to e3 i believe and then try to go back
over to f5 you have this d6 square that
could be annoying as well
so no forks but 92 check could be
dangerous for this king
i like knight f5 as a possibility here
knight d3 is an option but the queen
would just move knight g6 played
queen needs to stay in line with the
knight queen d8 check i feel like if you
go knight d6
queen f4 happens and you may win the b7
pawn which is actually not easy to win
because you walked into a pin
but you're getting your queen away from
the safety of this king
and this king could be susceptible to
some kind of perpetual check so here
comes knight f4 watch out for the king
11 seconds teddy is the one in more time
trouble all of a sudden
and he goes king h2 that way he can push
his g pawn and tiger king
that looks weird to me 97 check 97
looked good you could have forced the
queens off queen five
he takes this pawn he has no fear he's i
don't need to trade queens queen d7 back
and then queen f5 that's his idea of h4
which looks scary queen f5 check trading
the queens you want a second pawn you
win the game
so queenie a check nice find there this
punk queen h8 you can go back and forth
he said goes queen e4 h4 that was knight
f5 that's why g6 was played
protecting both squares queen comes back
to e3 now the pawn is pushing
here goes that pawn all right knight to
d6 is possible just don't blunder
checkmate here's a queen here knight g4
that's a really good defensive place
queen e5 check if you want it trade take
with the pawn you are up two pawns b5 is
tempting but i wouldn't go there just
yet but b5 would spring free this
outside pass pawn
king e3 is a blunder knight c2 checks oh
he lost in time
wow oh my gosh and look at lars he's
just like
uh karma my friend you know we're in a
pretty even matchup right now
but i know what happened in game two
game three
it's your time to lose so wow wow wow i
cannot believe that that just happened
here
oh my gosh what a match we've had it's
two to one lars oscar howard
in the lead teddy coleman up two pawns
in that final position
i don't even know what to make of this
so i will take the time during this
break to get my head
back in order both players really
playing some exciting chess
we'll be right back after this short
break is i'm not gm speechless
championship match
brought to you by chess.com
[Music]
and in this matchup between i am teddy
coleman and i am lars oscar hogg it is a
2-1 lead
for lars the norwegian player he is
jumped ahead
of teddy he won game one teddy struck
back in game two and lars wins game
three on the clock
down two pawns in the position but fair
is fair teddy did win game two on time
when he was
in a losing position so it evens out
right now lars is the lead but both
players should be
feeling pretty confident they've done a
good job they've gotten the positions
they've
wanted and particularly in this game
three with the white pieces teddy should
be happy
with how the game went so it's a close
one it's anybody's match at this point
and they are playing in this
quarterfinals
match here there's 300 to the winner the
three next three hundred dollars is
split by win percentage so every game
counts every point counts
and these players they just want to move
on they want to win this tournament
that's their focus and both of them they
have their chances so
the games are about to get back and here
we go we have
game four underway and we have f4
on move one by lars so he goes
for the birds opening and this is seen
as somewhat risky from white's point of
view because any time you push this
golden pawn that's upon f2
the pawn f7 your king can get in more
danger you open up a diagonal against
your king
so that can be a problem as the game
continues and look knight f6
very simple development by black if
knight g4 comes at the right moment
you're
already eyeing scores like e3 and f2 so
white is the one who needs to be a bit
careful he plays
e3 and he's kind of a player of my own
heart kind of said i play in online
blitz and now watch out
with the bishop of knight here if e4 e5
comes that will win
a piece so e4 is not defended right now
and this bishop can just drop back to h7
preemptively so i know what you're up to
but watch out for a timely e4 move that
would be
problematic for black but for now too
many pieces
are covering the square so it's not
actually a direct threat so black and
played move like c5 knight to d7 just
developing all these pieces all your
miners are
now you got to move e4 is coming
and that would be devastating to see
because i attack your bishop and then i
play e5
so you should either move your bishop
say to b4
that way if e4 is not impossible because
your knight is pinned
but even if it were possible e5 doesn't
win a piece and
alternatively you can drop your bishop
back to h7 or to g4
to make sure e4 doesn't even come with
tempo
so teddy does the bishop h7 he has just
over
four minutes lars over four and a half
minutes for himself so the opening
battle i would say has been won
by white even though black's position is
solid there's no weaknesses it's about
the time and i like the fact that lars
is up by half a minute and teddy can
think at some point about playing e5
that's a reasonable choice
but with the king still in the center i
probably wouldn't commit to that just
yet
queen e7 speaks to me that way you
retain some flexibility where's my king
wanna go does it want to go king side
can i go queenside if you go side you
may be walking into an attack because
you don't have that many defenders over
there
but at the same time maybe you can
launch an attack against this king on
g1 when there's pawn f4 that looks good
because it takes up space
but also it's easier to crack with a g5
so that's why i'm thinking perhaps teddy
wants the castle
long and get his king away from white's
king and lars he strikes too quickly
for that even to be considered so teddy
does play e5 that way white can't do the
same
and now i'm not really threatening to
take on f4
i'm just going to leave my pawn in place
if i'm thinking about this from teddy's
perspective
this pawn stops a lot of white's
activity and this bishop on c1 is behind
the pawn
if you commit to f5 that's a really
risky choice
while it makes the bishop on h7 look
pretty bad there's no more pawn tension
and your pawn
e4 isn't exactly the soundest pawn there
is and
black would try to get at that pawn and
castle very likely to the queen side
so remains to be seen how large reacts
he does play
f5 so i like it from a
for the point of view that it makes this
bishop look bad at some point there
could be h3
g4 g5 especially if this king comes this
way
which is why i think the king should end
up going to the queen side
but it's not risk-free there this bishop
comes to e3
puts pressure on the a7 pawn for example
these pawns
can start pushing up the board so i do
prefer
white's position i think that lars
should be confident
he should be enjoying the current
dynamic but as the game continues
this bishop on g2 isn't exactly the best
piece and it's going to need to defend
this pawn on e4 that's what black would
like to attack
so let's see what can
black do now a4 this says hey you don't
want to castle this way and a5 says
you're right i probably don't want to
castle queenside you still can
oddly enough because while you've pushed
upon in front of your king
it's hard to attack and by playing a5 b4
is not going to happen so teddy plants
his knight in c5
this pawn is under attack i would have
considered putting the bishop on b4
first and then attacking this knight on
c3 but okay knight c5 it does make sense
putting pressure on the e4 pawn bishop
e3
drops the pawn directly this queen is
doing an important job defending the
pawn
so white needs to figure out how to
continue in 92 it makes sense
opening up all the pieces to defend this
pawn
so this whole game is centered around
well the center this e4 pawn and black
would like to play g6 but you'll notice
that knight f6 would have lost its
defender which is why teddy
brought his knight back to d7 first and
g6 can be played
in the near future trying to open up
this bishop on the diagonal
so lars has developed very normally all
the pieces
have a function here black's pieces not
quite as much a bishop g5
could be played to try to offer an
exchange of those bishops but this
bishop can even drop right back to g1
and say
my bishop is better than yours i don't
want to trade
and of course rook to d1 trying to get
this d6 square
is possible if this bishop were ever to
leave the e7 square so i do likewise
position seems easier to play
both players concentrated right now
bishop g8
wow f6 let my bishop
play in this game too okay that's
actually pretty reasonable
because if you play f6 and say bishop f7
then you can castle more safely so
bishop f3 says if you play f6
guess what i'm going to give you a check
on the diagonal that's pretty clever
play by lars
responding to teddy's move with a bishop
move zone
and well what now f6
check bishop f7 takes takes this doesn't
look very friendly for the king
it's never going to find true shelter so
that's why lars put his bishop on f3 and
just to show you the difference
is let's say had he played rook to d1 f6
yeah you get your one check
but bishop f7 blocks it and that's a
queen that's a bishop the bishop wins
that battle so that's why lars
played bishop to f3 teddy here sitting
and thinking trying to figure out all
right what what next
how do i do this do i try to push g6
like
is that actually a reasonable try to
free this bishop up or
is that going to open the position and
the king is in the center can i castle
to the queen side
my king can't castle king said there's a
bishop in the way and if i cast a queen
side am i somehow going to walk into
a mating attack and the most important
thing right now is look at teddy time
he's a minute and nine seconds and a
tough position so he does in fact
allow the trade of bishops if i'm large
i'm trading there
and i'm going after this king and that
might involve a g4
an h4 g5 something like that but
teddy's gonna say you can't check with
me that quickly i do have some time
maybe that includes a queen d8 queen
eight to trade the queens
rook d8 was played instead let's try to
trade some brooks but this rook
you're playing a rook down in the
position because the rook is stuck
behind the king
and the king can't get out because the
queen's on h5 and what king g8 king
h7 no i'll put my queen on g6 and check
you off so your king
can't even move out the way so here
comes rook to d1
this position no fun for black none
whatsoever
and what next if you gain black
okay of course black is starting to win
a piece but if this piece we're not
hanging what is black's actual plan here
to get the pieces out
and on the flip side white needs to make
use of this open line
that's essential here maybe bishop takes
c5 is a move
and after takes you take this knight on
b6 i'm trying to get my rook
somewhere along this defile if i work
gets in the game black is in some huge
huge trouble
i'm just not quite seeing the knockout
blow right now
so lars he's sitting and thinking he
does have over two minutes to teddy's 56
seconds
but we've seen the clock dwindle we
somehow seen players who have had way
more time
spent too much of it and then they're
the ones who are scrambling to make the
final moves of the game
so right here lars takes that pawn on a5
okay this knight moves out the way this
is under attack so knight takes a4
seems pretty reasonable at this point
and this e4 pawn
isn't that well defended talked about
this a long time ago
but if this knight on c3 can be removed
then this pawn on e4 becomes a target
later in the game
so i move like knight c4 i can just take
this knight and then take this pawn
and steal your essential pawn but this
dynamic here is the most problematic
the black king can't get out so you need
to somehow get this rook if you could
play rook jumps
over king to d8 your position is
perfectly acceptable
but with your rook stuck on h8 you're
not a happy camper
so knight takes on a4 this part of b2 is
under attack knight c4 there is b5
that is available to black and this b2
pawn might be lost
and where is this knight actually going
so suddenly this is turning around and
teddy
has 35 seconds lars has a minute 25
still more time for white
but teddy's moves are becoming a bit
easier so if he can play them quickly
then he can try to bounce back here and
i see that that move was not approved of
and knight d2 was played and i don't
think that's going to
uh do the trip i think like rook a1
actually trying to get the open a file
would have been
useful for white but instead knight to
d2 so can you just take this pawn
because the rook if it goes to a1 i just
go knight a4 back and i
close down the a file so queen c8 play
instead queen e8
is probably the plan and i want to play
king f7 really really badly so if i play
queen eight
and your queen moves back somewhere and
then i can move my king up that's the
goal so look at this
you see the eval bar it's going down
king f7
or king g8 king hw you do have some time
knight h4 knight g6 does look scary but
teddy's gonna go king
to h7 and rook g8 as the knight comes in
look at this
rookie g8 he has 11 seconds left so he
is down on time
but his position is getting better this
pawn is under attack if you push it
in comes his knight to c3 which attacks
the rook attacks the pawn i guess
that might need to be a bit careful here
as it looks promising
just if you could take on h6 and follow
with queen takes hx it would be
checkmate but your rook would somehow
need to be on the h file to do the trick
and that's far away
so how is lars going to take over here
knight c3 i'm jumping in thank you don't
mind if i do
give me this pawn and you have to give
me this pawn you can play rook e1
and that defends the pawn tactically or
so it would seem but if the rookie one
takes bishop h6
haha knight f2 that is a fork i don't
have to recapture your bishop
instead i check you and i win your queen
in this manner so
that is something to keep an eye on uh
that black has available rook
a1 rook a7 okay i see this that looks
threatening but
if you move the bishop queen h6 is
checkmate he loses on time
teddy just loses some time he couldn't
find a move and he loses
on time here and i get it just bring up
i'm gonna bring up that
end position very quickly just to show
you the final tactic
that queen takes h6 check was the threat
if you move this bishop
anywhere let's say to c5 queen takes h6
is
checkmate because the king is on h7 the
g7 pawn is pinned
and that's why teddy he couldn't find a
move and he just loses on the clock
because look at this your bishop's under
attack
you know queen takes h6 is coming what
are you to do here it's just
that kind of position probably queen d8
to get into d1 that was necessary
to counter against this king but really
difficult to find with just a few
seconds in the clock so i understand
how teddy saw that game it's like this
one's gone
and really that game was about time
management
but also lars gave him credit he kept
preventing teddy from finishing his
development that rook on h8
it made one move it went to g8
eventually at long last
but he didn't have enough time to figure
out the rest of the game so
credit to lars he played a nice game
there and teddy with the white pieces
now we have a more standard setup it's a
nimble indian
the bishop comes to b4 to pin this
knight maybe you'll take it at some
moment
and the pawn will have to capture but
you have double pawns there but teddy
has not wasted a move playing a3
so if a3 then black is more inclined to
take the knight
because white spent this turn playing a3
which doesn't help the rest of the board
bishop d2 says okay you can take on c3
i'll take with my bishop
but he also could have castled and he
may not have spent time playing a3
but lars says i'm going to get your
bishop taste is that's fine with me i'll
take it right back with my rook
and look at my bishop on d3 staring at
your king my knight is developed
so i'm perfectly happy with this
position so it's just
you know a standard a strategic
battle i should say where white has the
bishop hair and you can try to keep the
bishop pair with bishop e1
but look at the stronghold over the e4
square by black's pieces
and you have to watch out because this
queen can venture in this rook can also
lift its way
up to the sixth rank and then this
attack
could be dangerous for the white king
but strategically
now i keep talking about this as a
strategic uh versus a tactical battle in
a way
that this is also kind of risky because
if white is able to
break through on the queen side you may
not have enough time to attack the white
king
because white is infiltrating on the
queen side so
a5 played if takes i think that lars
will throw in knight takes c3
and that way the rook can recapture on
a5 i don't want to take back with the
pawn
because then white has access to the c5
square and so
if this capture knight takes c3 removes
the guard or the a5 square
and then the rook can capture so lars
actually voluntarily takes on c3 brings
his knight to d7 guess what then i can
come to f6 and then
you know where maybe the e4 you can also
play for e5 as you have that square
defended
so teddy needs to figure out all right
what's the best way to react right now
do i put my queen on b3 do
i this e6 pawn and maybe not don't put
my queen on c2
to stop e5 because the f5 pawn is saying
well then i lose sight of my knight on
f3 right bishop takes f3 as possible
so even individual moves at this point
are not so easy for white
i think black's position is much more
simple your plan you brought your knight
out okay maybe i'll go negative six
maybe i'll go queen of six
maybe go rook f6 maybe i'll go e5 i see
all of these options for black
whereas white's moves for the most part
tend to have some kind of drawback and
queen e2 was played
this knight can simply hop in to f6 and
then maybe to e4
this pawn as mentioned go e5 but i
believe teddy's idea is to take and then
push his pawn to e4 so no
e5 e4 for you just like in the last game
when today was black he saw that epon
mobilizing he said i can also push
my own so
we have this set up knight f6 good move
by lars
trying to bring this knight into e4 i
would not be surprised if teddy
drops his knight back to d2 to deal with
that
idea and e5 even if it weren't attacked
twice is not
possible just yet because the f5 pawn is
hanging and needs the e6 pawn's defense
which means
perhaps d5 is a good move right i just
talked myself in this i thought e5 isn't
available to black
because it's f5 pawn but d5 is possible
because of this very
same f5 pawn and teddy moves the rook
back to c2 first
that way 94 did not come with a tempo
and
laura says okay queen e7 teddy says
don't mind if i do let's break open the
queen side
and now he has two pawns and the rook
defending the square this rook can
double on the c file
if black does capture and
well white looks like first of the punch
c6 is not out of the question either it
closes down the queen side
in large part but it pushes the bishop
back and takes over some space so
c6 i wouldn't that's not my first
instinct i don't want to play that move
but it's something you should consider
and if you're lars you may consider
putting your bishop on one of these two
squares
just to get outside of the pawn if
c6 is indeed the plan so bishop e4 to
trade bishops try to get this knight in
here
bishop d5 says you can't kick my bishop
off this great d5 square
so i don't mind if i sit on it so let's
see
lars down 10 seconds he takes a takes b
oh you don't you can actually decide to
take this first if you want to open the
c
file you could take on b6 and then take
this back because by taking on b6 you're
attacking the c7 pawn
so teddy has a choice but he shouldn't
spend too much time
making his move here that's been a fatal
flaw of his
we've seen him in pretty decent
positions and then he has 10 seconds
left
so right now is not the time to sit and
think for a minute
maybe think for half a minute because it
does change the trajectory of this game
but you cannot burn all of your time on
this one move and he's still thinking
two minutes and 15 seconds of counting
down lars now has a pretty
significant lead on the clock and i do
like white's position i don't
see a huge problem with it but i'm going
to see a problem with it
if he keeps thinking and i guess you
could actually throw the move c6 as well
pushing the bishop back and then taking
on b4 so he does have a lot to consider
i get it
i'm fully on board with it but we've
seen what happens to him when he spends
all his time
and that's why i'm advocating against it
so he's still thinking here
still hasn't made a move just make one
you got to make a good move quickly
rather than the best move slowly
so what i'm trying to figure out what
he's even considering and what he's
actually going to do here he takes on b6
and if i'm lars i would even just take
back right away
i don't want to calculate is this rook
takes c7 happening i
see the bishop can take on f3 but lars
spent
essentially 10 seconds to tell you a
minute and 15 seconds
and that's the biggest difference right
now
this knight gets the d5 score it is a
monstrous piece here it stops
any kind of rook c7 ideas it puts
pressure
on the d4 pawn this pawn can go to b5
but you want to double in the c file and
then it's like well so what
you double the c file no no no
you're not getting in and this knight on
d5 is helping so maybe white will play
e4
rook on c1 e4 type of stuff that way
you can challenge this knight and trade
it off but that's very committal
as well because your d4 pawn becomes
weaker and all that stuff so rook to b1
play protecting the b4 pawn
make sure that your queen is free to
move but move to where
what's the plan maybe bishop c4 to take
this knight i don't really like
leaving this diagonal because i just
have this in the back of my mind if the
black bishop gets the e4
that can be a problem and actually e4
would be a big blunder because it moves
like rook takes d3
and knight f4 and this e4 pawn is
a problem it's hanging so do not play e4
here
i do not recommend that and what else
can i recommend this queen is doing an
important duty of defending this uh
bishop
also the c3 square the knight would like
to jump in you know queen e2 knight c3
thank you for
material so white's position remains
harder to play maybe bishop
b5 and bishop c6 that way at least
i'm infiltrating on one of the c file
squares and maybe two of them because
the c8 square is also defended by the
bishop
and my bishop on d3 isn't doing all that
much so actually bishop b5 to c6 looks
very reasonable
just trying to get this bishop off and
rook a8 says
okay i'm gonna take over the a-file
still i'm looking at this idea
for white like let me get my bishop in
and h3 okay deliberate let's see what
black can do so i was looking at it from
white's perspective now i'm gonna flip
over to black's perspective
how do i improve here if my knight goes
to f6 is it coming to e4
perhaps but i'm giving up the c7 square
so
queen e8 was the choice queen can come
to a4 queen come to h5
i like the flexibility of this move and
it also stops the idea i was talking
about bishop
b5 to c6 so teddy goes bishop c4 but he
doesn't want to take this
the bishop lands on d5 and that's not
exactly
promising for white's position so knight
e1
that way i don't blunder my knight on
the square the g pawn is pinned so
knight takes
something like knight takes e3 is a big
threat here so 91 is played this knight
could also try to go to the f4 square
eventually
probably not yet bishop f1 can be played
just to defend this g2 pawn
and if this knight were here then you
could take on d5 and put your knight in
f4 so it would tactically be
okay look at teddy rook a2 good move 34
seconds left
lars now under min on the clock a rook
trade is offered and
with one pair of rooks off white feels
less cramped white did have less space
so by trading off the rooks there is
more space for your remaining pieces f4
watch out for a shot like that
because this rook on b1 is in line with
the queen but the bishop is defending
that's square for now
so f4 probably doesn't work out rook c1
well
open file let's take it now i can
consider taking on d5
to get my rook to c7 doesn't quite do
the trick just yet so i wouldn't take on
d5 until
it's necessary so knight d3
is not even possible because if you take
an e3 i take back with my pawn and g2 is
protected
if knight d3 knight takes b4 i guess
that's one of the problems knight f4
hits the queen though and
does both so interesting moment here
maybe there's rook takes a2 though
that's probably the
biggest issue is there's like all these
tactics that play here knight c3 at some
point but rook takes a2
should do the trick because you take
here take and
this is under attack this is under
attack here
takes takes and thank you for your rook
at the end so that's the
problem with moving your knight from e1
is the tactics will favor
black so bishop c4 knight f6 bishop d3
knight e4
okay pieces are moving trades are being
offered finally that knight is out of
there
but when you play f3 look at the e3
square and when you look at e3 look at
d4
a pawn chain is only as strong as the
base of the pawn chain
this is the base now before it was on f2
and everything was safe
now it's an e3 which doesn't feel quite
as good but look at teddy brings the
knight in and he's in a five seconds
he's got to move queen c3 off from the
queen trade he thinks that he's getting
safer by doing this
we have a trade knight back to c3 b5
knight a4 watch out because this pawn
could be a target but that's why the
nitrate is offered and i believe that
this position is quite
level but with teddy's clock being a 5.7
seconds left that's how things can go
wrong even if you have
an objectively drawn position you can
blunder into things but look
all the pawns are in dark squares so
this bishop is strong but it can't
attack anything
and the king can't get in there's no
access points for the king
so i would just you can even leave the
pawns and put your bishop to c4 no king
e6 for you
and yeah he's gonna shuffle back and
forth
and there's no threat like you could
take out f4 i just take back these pawns
are all defending so
it takes 2.8 seconds though you got to
move 3.1 not
showing the steadiest bullet hand
throughout this match this far bishop e2
he could play or he's going to trade
everything
and play bishop e2 now but f4 the king
starts getting in
you have to be a little bit careful here
bishop d3 but he made 0.3 seconds left
he lost some time again he can't control
it
right now it's slipping away because he
has no time remaining
and teddy in those moments he's spending
too much time early and he's not
showing the confidence when he gets into
just under 10 seconds remaining he's the
one who's
nervous and he can't make the move in
time and that's why lars has this four
to one lead
even though that position was
objectively
equal or you saw the zeros in the eval
bar didn't have time to
reach the conclusion that he wanted so
now here's the black pieces
lars goes for a more standard opening
instead of the birds opening with one f4
we see that we're in pretty much a
normal position
bishop on f4 reminiscent of the london
system but the pawns on c4
so it's kind of like a hybrid like
instead of just in london with a closed
dynamic
it's an open london and castle's king
side makes sense
white is going to try to castle kingside
soon as well bishop e2 first
and castle and black can play for c5
this is a standard way to chop
at white center as you push the pawn to
c5 you say i'm going to trade some
pieces off
my knight wants to go to c6 but it
doesn't attack anything without the pawn
putting pressure on the center so i like
the move c5 here
teddy is considering his options he
plays knight to d5 which i also like
if you take and i take with the pawn
well how are you going to win back this
pawn on c4
not seeing it and otherwise i'm
threatening to take on c3 and win a pawn
in this manner so
knight takes pawn takes bishop takes
where's this rook going
where is this rook on here here
rook c1 bishop b2 this rook
has nowhere to go and yet the
computer still likes white maybe there's
some kind of queen b3 queen takes b7
like rook b1
something like this where you end up
getting the b7 pawn and the c7 pawns
also under attack so it's funny how you
can kind of blunder
and it still works out well for you
sometimes these things happen
and chest is strange like that and
knight g5 also is an idea in such a
position so
bishop took and went back to a5 this is
smarter
and it's the second time where teddy
with the black pieces has stolen
a pawn in the earlier game he took this
g4 pawn
and he was doing a good job of fending
off the attack here there won't be an
attack but it's going to be a positional
grind where black's pieces don't exactly
have that much
space and this pawn c7 needs to have an
eye kept on it but this bishop can just
sit on b6 which defends the b-pawn
along the file and it protects c7
directly so
this knight can now develop i prefer the
black's position in a blitz game
i see that the evaluation bar says white
has a slight edge
it's because the center looks good
you're fully developed with your minor
pieces and your rooks out that that's
all good that all looks great
but how do you actually say i'm in this
for the long run
you are down a pawn and you start
feeling that as the game continues
like wait am i going to get my material
back is there a way for me to maybe lose
some of my
activity but gain material back and i
see that queen e2 was played and the
eval bar dropped a little bit and that's
how tricky these positions are
i don't know the perfectly precise move
in that position but clearly queenie two
was
not the number one best move and it
makes perfect sense
you're playing e4 to get this bishop
and to push your pawns in the center
bring this rook to d1
where your rook's in line with his queen
so i get what white's doing and yet
it's saying oh black is doing really
well and it's because black has an extra
pawn
so h3 no bishop g4 for you if i played
e4 too soon maybe you'd play here
and then my d4 pawn is weak so instead
h3 is played this knight can go to f6
but that gives the e5 square it's the
knight
so it's a four jump for both and teddy
does go knight f6
he's saying my extra pawn speaks volumes
here
maybe he'll play c6 maybe he'll play
bishop c7 the bishop on a5
isn't exactly doing that much it's
taking away the e1 square from a rook
but there doesn't really need to or want
to go to the e1 score anyway
so i think that c6 would be a reasonable
play
especially if you can get bishop c7 to
follow and maybe knight d5 move
is coming as well because if i get
knight to d5 i'm attacking this maybe i
have some knight c3
ideas so lars plays bishop h2 i like
that move
if you want to play knight d5 go ahead
now i have e4 with the fork my bishop on
f4 is no longer under attack so i like
this move bishop h2
it's just saying i'm gonna play safely
but now knight e4
is reasonable bishop e4 is also
reasonable and
c6 as i mentioned it's played you can
play b5 not now
because the c6 spawns under attack but
if you wanted to be aggressive b5 was
available
the knights on e5 f3 maybe e4 to come
maybe g4 hitting this bishop so black
still lacks a bit of like play for the
pieces
your pieces are about to get attacked
and white's pieces are
perfectly safe in this position
knight d5 is e4 okay not great bishop c7
that looks good knight d7 perhaps is
next where i can trade off this knight
on e5
and training pieces should help the side
with extra material and in this case
it's black with an extra pawn so 97
looks
plenty reasonable to me
and there's played so e4 is a
possibility the bishop can go
sit back on g6 and maybe the knight will
take it but we're starting to trade
pieces this bishop 182
i can capture with check and now we're
getting into
an easier simplification where black
remains upon ahead
so bishop g6 f4
wow f5 one of the ideas there's a bishop
on c4 very powerful
this 95 wants to stay here and teddy
needs to figure out can he take
on e5 with this knight and perhaps d
takes e5 it may look worrisome but it
would look even worse if this rook could
come back to f1
but something like takes takes and g4
and f5
that doesn't look very fun who wants to
see themselves get attacked in this
manner
it may not work out perfectly for white
maybe there's like a queen h4 at some
point
and a bishop b6 check and maybe there's
problems
in white's position as well but it feels
pleasant
for white at first glance with a rook on
the open file so teddy does take he
plays bishop b6 and
well queen h4 different move order same
position
that i was calling for but i see the
eval bar it's in white's favor
i don't know if i would agree with that
from a practical point of view
bishop h5 is kind of a threat because g4
loses the sight of this pawn on h3 and
he plays g4 voluntarily so he gives up
this pawn to play f5 and trap the bishop
okay
wow now there is a lot to figure out
here
can i hmm what can you do here so queen
h3
f5 bishop is trapped but can i take a
bunch of times in f5 or is the king on
g8 actually somehow worse than the king
on h1
it's weird when you're pushing your
pawns the king on h1 looks like
there's a lot of air in front of it that
could be dangerous but it's this king on
g8
that could see itself in harm's way
i would somehow take and after f5 i
would
allow this capture but i wouldn't take
here i don't want this bishop to look
strong so i'd make him like rook to d8
and after it takes take i say well is
your bishop that strong
you have a bishop for what three pawns
here and your bishop
isn't that powerful so something like
this could be teddy's best bet
and instead he says no no i want my
bishop i'm going to play h5 and i see
that eval bar it approves it's saying
that black is just hanging right in this
thing but because white is down material
one pawn in fact and still the eval bar
says it's
pretty decent that would scare me and
just by the looks of this right
aesthetically white's position looks
powerful look at all these pawns here
marching forward and bishop h7 maybe
that's the move i know you're giving up
a pawn on e6 but the bishop will be free
and teddy decides to keep the material
but that's not the way to go i don't
i don't feel and i would have taken the
jeep 100 i would have taken this way
and brought my rook to g there's a
bishop here so i can't go with g1 just
yet
but i wanted to go rook to g1 but that's
uh
taking towards the center instead of
away from it
and we get to this position where e6
very tempting and
the point of e6 is if you take and i
take with my pawn i'm throwing e7 with
check against your king but takes with
the bishop now this i don't like
from lars's point of view i think that
the position is opening up and somehow
black's king is getting safer unless
there's some kind of timely
bishop e5 and a checkmate here but
that's why teddy when rook d8 he's
trying to trade off this attacking piece
give me the d file and this pawn h3 is
still hanging by the way
you shouldn't forget about that and i
want to get my bishop to d4
where it defends this pawn on g7 so i
will give you my b7 pawn
have fun with this irrelevant queenside
pawn it may restore material quality
but it's not going to be sufficient so i
think the next rook can
and maybe should come over to d8 as well
and said taste is
trading one rooks is good enough i'm
taking on h three now
g4 is under attack if you take bishop
takes at five can happen
uh teddy's handling as well and lars has
a minute and 10 seconds teddy is 41
seconds
so a lead on the clock for white but
black is up
two pawns and it's white king that
suddenly looks like it's in
far worse shape so black was on the
defensive now black is
on the offensive and up materials that's
not a good combination
for lars and i would try to make a move
like g5
just to go after this king somehow but
it could be a bit slow
f6 if it helps me get a discovery
against your queen that
should be considered but f6 perhaps just
rook takes f6
and then you're getting checkmate on the
f1 square so
bishop c4 played clearing out space on
the e file maybe there's a quick
little check meeting attack but i can
play my work to g8 my bishop to d4 my
queen to c3 all of these possibilities
but teddy takes in g4 and the evo does
not like that not one bit
rook takes g7 is possible here
that is a distinct possibility and there
is play because king takes
queen e7 check give me your rook
with check and your king's in trouble 23
seconds left
for teddy he needs to find a move here
queen f3 looks safe but the problem is
you trade queens as bishop lands on e5
your king's caught in the corner that's
not so safe after all
so gotta move gotta move he takes bishop
takes f5 what a brave choice
queen e5 there's queen f3 checkmate
okay so this king is in trouble this
king is in trouble i think that white's
king looks like it's in worse shape
but where is the mate
maybe rook g5 and queen e5 or queen b2
kind of thing
rook chief i played but oh my goodness
teddy finds an
instant wow and he gets we got a fist
pump from teddy
we get a comeback time fist pump by
teddy let's look at that final position
one more time
that was a really just crazy finish here
rook g5 it clears out the diagonal for a
check but after bishop e4
takes rook f1 bishop takes queen takes
bishop g1
that is check and mate the bishop
defense that king's caught in the corner
that would be a checkmate so we'll go
back to the new game here
but teddy bounces back with a win and
now he gets the white pieces he is down
four to two
this has been an up and down match
between these two
it's been pretty level i mean the score
says what it says is clearly in lars's
favor
but i feel like during the games
just the chess on the board has been
both sides with chances though
lars has been quicker and we'll see how
that helps him
as we go to the quicker time controls
but teddy the white piece is now
queen 22 nimzo and both sides playing a
bit slowly considering this is mainline
theory
a3 if the bishop takes you take with the
queen here we go
and typically black tries to strike in
the center with d5 and here lars goes
for the more solid approach
d6 and that's to play for pawn to e5
and only white has a dark square bishop
so if i can put my pawns on dark squares
your bishop doesn't have as great a
scope so
it's different style it's perfectly
reasonable but if you played b4 bishop
b2 hoping to
use diagonal well dick's knight can come
to d7 the spawn
queen on e7 pawn e5 and it's actually
not as promising as it may seem
teddy energized now yeah teddy did seem
pretty pumped
right that was a crazy finish and
these momentum ships really do happen
where you win one game where you're
on the edge the whole way and then you
win and you find a checkmate at the end
you start feeling rejuvenated you're
like this is my match
i can handle this and there are just
over four minutes
in this longest time patrol so we'll see
if
teddy can get one more win and
uh if he can do that then he cuts the
deficit in half because he's down by two
points
but lars going for the principal move e5
we mention this pawn structure
everything is settled now d takes e5
here for black if you take with the
queen
this bishop takes f6 and they get a ruin
your kingside pawn structure so
that's what take the pawn knight f3
simple development
now you need to defend your pawn e5 and
knight e4
is an idea at some point just not yet
because
i'll take your queen and then you take
my queen but i take your rook at the end
so
94 should be thought about and it goes
to show when there's a pin
and the piece that's being pinned to is
not a king the piece
can still move and sometimes moving it
is actually quite good but just not yet
so sitting at thinking and if you castle
maybe 94 is good because
castle knight e4 takes
takes bishop takes check king h1 and
this is a good lesson in not stopping
your calculation early
i have two pieces for a rook but where's
my knight going exactly
oh that's right it's not really going
anywhere so i'm like rook to e1 could
just trap this knight in its place so
you know this is the kind of thing the
kind of tactics that these highly rated
players they're looking at they're
trying to see it all the way through
but lars says i don't want to worry
about that let me just play h6
knight e4 maybe it's a possibility in
some universe
just not this one and bishop h4
teddy has to look out for pawn to g5 and
will we see some kind of sacrifice on g5
probably not so g5 bishop g3 knight to
e4
yes black has exposed his king somewhat
by pushing his pawns there but he forks
the queen and the bishop
and lara says you know this is not your
game you can play g5 with a clear
conscience
if i play g5 i'm gonna be worrying for
the rest of this one so let's play
bishop f5 first
develop the piece connect the rooks to
one another this pawn a4 means that b4
there will be an amps on so you can just
press forward on the side of the board
and maybe i'll try to use it for my
knight it's a good square to get into
and from white's perspective maybe spawn
a4 has gone too far maybe later in the
game i can attack it with a
bishop d1 or something like that and
grab it so teddy goes knight to d2
i think we understand why he is covering
the e4 square
so that there won't be a fork if this
bishop has to go to g3 which makes g5
way less enticing i don't want to play
that anymore it just opens up my king
without any of the benefits
of getting my knight into the e4 square
so lars sitting and thinking
teddy once again down almost a half
minute on the clock
we've seen this pretty much throughout
the entire match where teddy is the one
with less time on the clock and for lars
he is up f 42
should be happy about the chess he's
played thus far but when you lose one
game especially by getting checkmated
you start feeling wait a sec am i
calculating
that well am i doing the right thing and
so lars may be second
guessing himself and just checking this
position deeply and look at him he's
just
okay now i finally shifted his gaze but
before that he was just
staring at the board i don't know what
part of the board it was
but that was intense he has a really
stair that just doesn't stop so lars
takes a swig calms down now he looks
chill so maybe he's going through the
emotions on camera for all of us here
but you know it's just a change in uh
just how he's
looking at this position and well he's
down 30 seconds
from up a half minute to down a half
minute without
making a move on the 15 turn he plays
bishop h7
which is a move that he's a minute and a
half for
but you're kind of like for what why did
you spend so much time on this move and
that's not to be overly critical of the
guy he's playing good chess
and perhaps he just didn't see a better
move to make but these are the type of
decisions you need to make more quickly
and i've been
pretty harsh in a way on teddy to this
point for doing that and now
lars it's his turn where he didn't need
to spend
all of that time and i do this myself so
it's kind of a do as i say now as i do
moment
but he didn't need to waste all the time
playing bishop h7 the movie could have
played in
30 seconds rather than a minute and 30
seconds so anyway the bishop's on h7
it's still on a great diagonal teddy
doesn't have a clear plan to work with
f4 is like somewhat tempting if you want
to rip open the position and
try to get to this knight and pin it but
f4 carries its own risk where after the
pawn takes
now this queen is looking good on the e
file so
f4 i'm still interested i'm looking at
it
but i can understand why it would be a
bad move in fact rather than a good one
so teddy now doing the same thing if he
plays rook a to d1 or something like
that
you didn't need to spend all this time
playing rook rookie d1 or bishop f3 you
don't need to spend all this time
but it's all right you know maybe he's
gonna take and put his bishop on d5 or
he's going to just take on c6
to give block a compromised pawn
structure over here
i would play some kind of rook to d a
probably rook f to d8 because my rook
feels
important for taking the a4 pawn he
choose the a rook
and now this is d3 square to use thanks
this bishop on h7
so rook f to d1 makes some sense to me
rook a to d1
also makes sense rook d3 you know is
what
black is aiming for so this is not out
of the question either
bishop takes c6 just to hurt the pawn
structure and
another reason why it'd be better if
this rook were here is this rook could
come to b8 and put pressure on the b2
pawn
and then this rook on f8 would already
be on d8 using the open line so the rook
and f8 is kind of not doing anything
and he takes the c6 b takes c6 you can
throw in rook d3
that's possible but i would have just
taken on c6 as he does
and now lars is the men in the clock and
teddy's position is getting worse so
he's going after this e5 pawn i like
that that's a
hanging piece rook e8 then i go rook to
d1 and i don't have to worry about
his default rook d3 i say thank you for
your pawn e5 don't mind if i grab that
one
so lars has a tough choice e4 knight d4
in the c6 pawn
and that shuts down your bishop so i
actually kind of like what teddy just
did there i see that the evaluation bar
has gone slightly very slightly in
black's favor
but in blitz chess playing with double
pawns
is very difficult i really feel that way
that having pawns like this is never fun
having an isolated pawn here isn't that
great either do not play rook to d2
because you are walking to 94 at g5
first but 94
second and that's a fork so teddy now
down to 57 seconds he made queen a5
relatively quickly a4
c7 e5 that queen is doing it all
from the a5 square attacking all these
pawns b2 can be captured
but do you really want this pawn for
this pawn maybe the a pawn later in the
game
can become a runner and that's not so
fun
so bishop f6 queen f6 queen takes c7 is
another idea
i think just taking on a4 makes the most
sense
putting pressure on the next pawn on c6
and teddy's 40 seconds left he's half
his opponent's time he's
just got to make a move just got to play
in the flow of the position here
and the more you think oftentimes when
you're
in a scramble you're you make the worst
moves honestly it's weird how that works
but
these players are so strong that their
intuitions are often correct and
he when bishop takes f6 the eval bar not
a fan of this decision
and it frees the queen up which puts
pressure on this maybe there's going to
be some bishop e4
right immediately attacking darren
wow back rank check me i was like did i
just witness a really bad peace blunder
but if rookie five you can just check me
in the back ring
queen eight is mate that's just mate
so that's why lars said i'm gonna put my
bishop on c2
teddy's knight to g4 tempo against your
queen this rook is still under attack so
you need to move the queen out of the
way first
and where to queen g5 would trade the
queens off the board because your
queen's under attack and your
rook is under attack over here but does
black want to trade queens
seems reasonable with this rook being
very promising but this could be a rook
d2 at the end
and that bishop is pinned so we're
getting far down the line here but
that's how you need to calculate
you really need to think deeply before
trading queens and
every move has its consequences so
lars deep in the think tank where does
the queen go
g6 e7 okay e7 hits the a3 but look at
teddy he says my rook's under attack but
so is yours
you can take the rook i'll take yours
you can take my knight i'll take your
bishop so
this is what's happening here and he
takes we have this captain queen e4
going after two pawns at once i said
take my
g4 pawn this a pawn i talked about it
earlier that's going to be a past
pawn for white whereas this king he lost
one of his defenders
but maybe not the end of the world here
so it's a slight advantage for white
it's getting okay the queen does protect
this i'm
watching out for blunders here we are
getting to that kind of time scramble
h5 here comes h4 rook d a check now what
queen eight is there mate
queen eight and back here mate okay
queen d1 please take me i'll bring my
rook behind my past pawn
so it's at h4 it's like can we trade him
by rook d4 trading rook d4
the pawn ending is winning because of
this past pawn so teddy is able to steal
pawn
and now he wants to keep this pawn if he
can not so easy so he's going to go
check oh he could throw them to check
first
check first and then rook d7 was better
because f7 would have been hanging as
well
so teddy makes it slight and accuracy he
can play rook d3 rook c3 he's going to
do that
king up king up this way bring the king
in e4 is fine
but now the king can't even come into c5
king d6 king c5
but candy takes their c5 check i guess
they're just in time to do that
so teddy is better here up a pawn and
it's in the past a pawn
and he has pawns on both sides of the
board this is the flaw
of double pawns is white is essentially
up two pawns in this position
if we think about it in terms of a king
and pawn end game
so rook c3 back as possible plays it
this king wants to come to f1 can you
get five oh
missed opportunity that king could have
run right into the g6 square it's still
coming up the board
g5 the king over this rook d3 king g4
king h5
puts his king here i'm not loving the
way he's playing it but his advantage is
still a huge f6
you're gonna trade by rook d3 or rook g3
like that take the rook
nice try cheeky move and lars his face
i thought he was doing it to be tricky
but he just didn't realize
that his rook would be captured after
rook takes a3
and wow what an ending there to this
game to this time segment
we finished the five plus one time
segment four to three
lars oscar how in the lead and for teddy
you have to be
counting your blessings there you're
like wow i made it out only down one
game after being down three and for lars
saying well i've had big leads on the
clock
there's something going wrong in some of
these games and teddy is doing
really well in transitions in this game
there was
both rooks were under attack all of a
sudden pieces started being traded
and at like a certain moment there teddy
was able to
figure out a way to trade queens then
offer the rook trade and see that the
king and pawning game would be winning
so
he did a really nice job there lars to
his credit he's been doing well on the
clock he's been outplaying teddy in a
number of different positions
as well so this match it's one game lead
for lars oscar have it feels like it's a
true battle
we'll return a few minutes for more
action from this i'm not gm speeches
champion match brought to you by
chess.com
[Music]
so
and we return i'm pumped to be joined by
my partner in crime
grand mastermind hamilton amman it's a
4-3 lead right now for
lars oscar hogg but we're getting into
the quicker time control so
now that we're here what would advice
would you give each player
well uh first of all what's up robert
hello everybody
bringing a new meaning to the phrase
better late than never so
good to be here and uh pumped for this
match which
is very close right now teddy i mean
keeping that score
4-3 um you know as we concluded the
five-minute portion i think is already a
a good sign
for him going forward i mean we we all
know what kind of a beast
lars can be in the bullet portion but
just to have this match
uh within reach right now i think if
you're teddy coleman you're feeling
pretty good
yeah especially after being down four
games to one winning those last two
games
he must be gaining some confidence
feeling like he can do this thing and
now that we get into the three minutes a
whole different ball game
and we just remind everybody that this
match will continue here with
coleman and how but let's remind
everybody what happens on tuesday
because on tuesday night
we'll be gotham chess international
master levi rosman taking on
eric rosen that's tuesday 6 p.m pacific
time
amman i know we're not doing predictions
for that match yet we're still in the
midst of this one
but any uh kind of thoughts about what
we'll see come tuesday
yeah that that is sort of a heavyweight
streamer match up
um you know i i think there's gonna be a
lot of very firm takes
you're not gonna say hey uh you know i
just wanna see a good match i think
you're going to see a lot of people
very decided you know i want i love you
to win i want eric to win
um but that's that's going to be a
pretty exciting matchup
can i call that one i'm not sure i can
on paper i feel like
levy should be the favorite but um you
know
if we've seen you know this match
against james canty for example um it
all depends
what kind of shape you're in on match
day that's true
and well match day is here and we have
moves we have
f4 for the second time from lars and
among this bird's opening i said it
doesn't it's not seen very regularly it
has its flaws and i think that's one of
them is if you get your bishop to c5
teddy last time puts bishop on d6 but
these dark squares on the king side can
be vulnerable
and it's such a weird concept because in
chess it's like you play
the bird as white it's like hang on
isn't this just a dutch with an extra
move
it's it never makes sense to me almost
that i rack my brain i'm like wait why
isn't this good this should just be an
opening that's
normal for black but with an extra move
so i don't know can you explain that
phenomenon robert
i guess the dutch is just that bad
you even get an extra tempo and it's not
doing you any favors but look at this i
mean it seems
like teddy's playing a straightforward
game e5 coming next the queen is on
e2 here in harm's way i like black's
position
yeah agreed um basically skipping the c
pawn
um in teddy's position the pawn doesn't
need to be on c5
he's chosen to play knight c6 bishop c5
and it's not often that
that normal that you play knight c6 in
front of the c pawn
uh in these structures so i like it you
pointed out he's going for a quick e5
and if e5 happens keep in mind there's
not going to be you know
mass captures followed by d4 forking
because that would be pinned
to the queen and the king on the e file
wow an e4
talk about a move that i could never
play with my king in the center
there wasn't even a threat of pawn takes
i don't think because the e5
opening up would favor uh black there so
uh
instead we see bishop g4 c3 that takes
away the d4 square
e5 remains a big possibility for black
but
oman i see the eval bar how does black
prove the advantage here
it's a great question because honestly i
think it can be very tricky sometimes
it requires a move like e5 but i was
actually going to say robert after the
move e4 hitting the bishop maybe then it
was time for e5
kind of a weird move but might be the
only time that you could have punched
that in because
now see the difference you play e5 later
f5 happens and white's looking to kind
of close things down
right and a5 play here but there must
have been something quicker maybe
there's
a knight d4 sacrifice at some point
because i'm helped by that i see the
eval bar going crazy so there must be
some tactic here
and knight d4 just taking back with the
e pawn and going after the e4
maybe that's something uh what else can
be played here there's clearly a tactic
now it's about putting it together right
yeah that that makes a lot of sense i'm
also looking at like bishop takes
f5 like if you force me to play
something tactical
maybe i'm trying to play bishop f5 e4
just sort of
jam that pawn down your throat and bring
the knight to e5 because remember white
can't castle either
so it's not like the very next move
white is just going to be
safe right and easy for us to say
because we see that eval bar going crazy
the players have no idea
and queen v8 triangle queen a7 and this
king still can't castle but now you have
to take on f3 he does so bishop takes
back
and this king doesn't need a castle no
king f1 king g2 and watch out for these
pawns storming
for white on the king side yeah i i
if this hasn't already done this i can
see this completely turning around
um because this looks like a g4 g5 as
you mentioned
uh pawn storm that i don't see a good
way out of i actually really like that
maneuver queen b8 queen a7 quite
creative
from teddy but i kind of question like
what the threats are
for for black and that's so annoying
when you play
look at all the black's pieces on
reasonable squares including this queen
and yet white has this advantage because
black has no
plan at least none yet and one of the
deals here is this pawn on c3 takes away
such important squares from black's
pieces so how to continue maybe knight
to b6
trade off white's knight on c4 that
could be an idea but i just don't see an
actual plan i see some moves but
nothing that says five moves down the
line this is what i like to see from
black's point of view
yeah that's a good point and in blitz
chess i think
what you brought up is exactly what
makes this so hard to play
with the black pieces is that having a
plan first is not having a plan
usually the guy with a plan in bliss
chess is is gonna be happier queen a6
played adding some pressure to the
knight and you mentioned knight b6
he might be intending it now that he can
maybe get the queens off
uh you know with the same idea yeah
because these pawns do look menacing
where if a timely f6 or g6
the king on jake could be in trouble so
without the queens on the board then
there's no checkmating attack but white
still has the space black can't actually
have a counter shot that's the big
problem i'm still looking at knight d4
even though i know it shouldn't work i'm
that frustrated to have black's position
here
my pieces are stuck yeah no it is super
frustrating
you know keep in mind that structure
because pawn on c3 look at how much work
it's doing
bishop on c5 knight on c6 none of these
pieces can
join the action um and bishop e3 played
okay
not a fan of that move at all robert
i was looking at knight d4 you know like
you you went bishop e3 i was already
talking about knight d4 so that p
sacrifice came with a little bit of
but i get it we're here knight can come
to c5 now for
teddy and perhaps he should have played
knight to c5
even before trading queens because then
the knight was coming d3 with
check and there's the b3 square and all
this stuff is hanging but
yeah it's still knight to d5 for lars
and he says
what's your night doing mine's better
yeah i mean you can't complain about a
knight on d5
if you're lars in this position but keep
in mind even though
we have traded queens that's not
necessarily the end of the attack i mean
you can still launch a pretty serious
attack
uh without the queens on the board h4 h5
h6 um
and and that king is gonna be there's
gonna be some questions asked to that
king and in the end game there's gonna
be some pretty dangerous pass bonds
uh for teddy to deal with absolutely and
that's why teddy brought his knight back
to e7
and put his pawn on f6 and i don't want
you to start pushing your pawns
the king is open you made this point
that the king is not fully safe here
you can't even bring your king to f7
because bishop h5 would be a very nasty
check
but trading off rooks that feels like it
helps black
yeah trades are good basically if i feel
like if he can solidify
a position on the dark squares here um a
knight g8
yeah is the defensive move this is where
you almost wish you could play checkers
and go rook takes g8
and knight takes f6 but that tactic is
not going to exist and what is teddy
turning this game around a little bit
robert he just stole upon him so the a4
pawn not the first time today we've seen
teddy take that pawn
and now black is up upon white's trying
to go bishop c4 take on g8
so teddy says preemptively let me go
rook g7 pin your knight and h5 was a big
threat which is why the brookman's h2
yeah you might laugh at the move rook h2
but um it's a really good blitz move by
lars he recognizes
peace trades especially the rooks uh is
going to be teddy's position is going to
be super easy to play after that
and look at this teddy bring the rook to
d7 smart bring the king out of the
corner and now work g7 back
if you want to you can just bring your
rook to that open line but there's no
threat for white you take
over the c4 square by playing your pawns
to c6 to a4 in this chain
and now teddy's just taking over the
board he is um
the knight is mobilized from g8 knight
to c4 is going to be really good but
careful about knight c5 to e6 that is
what lars is up to
good call because then the king is not
saving knight c5 rook g7 96 so you can't
play for g7
you have to rookie 7 but knight e6 was
possible
that's the blunder you called it robert
only place that that knight could go oh
and that's got to be just heartbreaking
because teddy was fending him off
but this has been a theme in the match
time trouble has done him in
and that position he was actually much
much better and the eval bar was saying
pretty much winning for black yeah the
only thing about that game is
uh i guess if you're teddy you can't
feel that bad because
i i think he'd be the first to admit
that that was just not the right game
for him he
he could have punched in some tactics
earlier but uh the way that game went it
actually felt like lars was
in control for most of it hit a really
good position so
uh you know right when you got your
chance at the end you just
had invested so much time to get there
that you couldn't capitalize
and teddy clearly worked on his response
to the bird's opening during the break
because
that happened once and now he puts
bishop on c5 rather than d6 if he gets
another break
to look at that opening lars probably
would should not play that again because
it was saying minus two
something like that there were tactics
flying that teddy couldn't quite work
out
yeah and lars is going to know that it
might be safe to play in this
three-minute portion because
hey you know the guy is stuck in this
match he doesn't have time to
go look at the evaluation bar himself
and
check his analysis in that opening
that's right and so we get a more
standard theoretical line in the queen's
game decline
the knight went from b8 to d7 to f8 to
e6
and now it's like wait okay it's here
what's going on the good news about this
knight is it helps for a c5 push and
puts pressure on the d4 pawn because
white wants to play f3
and eventually e4 and get a big center
and there's your push
yeah and f3 is usually an indicator to
play the move c5 because if you play c5
first
you're still going to get that isolated
pawn but what the
black player wants to do is play c5
after f3 so the pawn on e3 is always a
target you say hey
you want to take me on c5 establish your
isolated pawn position is white
be my guess but then then you almost
wish you could take the move f3 back so
c5 is well timed there that's exactly
the case if you take
then you also while you're pressing the
clock you push your pawn back to f2
because then your pawn structure is safe
but with the pawn e3 taking on c5 is
actually very risky
and even if black takes on d4 and you
take back with the pawn
you're not unhappy with this at all your
pieces are doing very well and the d5
pawn is about to mention that is there
bishop f6
and knight takes d5 yeah there's um
there's a move that lars played he
played
uh h6 and uh usually
what i'm used to in this opening is that
the knight actually goes
to g5 um so that could have been a move
that he maybe forgot
or should have played earlier it blocks
that pin and then if the bishop wants to
trade for a knight
it takes on g5 so you don't get that f6
knight
uh i think you were right that that was
a moment where you could have just taken
a free pawn i think
it looked like it to me and said teddy
drops the bishop back to f2 which
we can't criticize too much because he's
protecting this e3 pawn
and now he's playing this isolated queen
palm position his rook is in the right
place against the
d5 pawn and behind the queen so a movie
e4
is probably even possible here bishop f5
is a thematic idea
he says let's just play simple chess my
rook can come to d1 and i'll double
against this pawn but
the e3 pawn amman you mentioned it i'm
looking at it it feels like it's a
sustained issue
right yeah we're we're all looking at
the same uh pawn i
am not a fan of rook d2 rip d1 it feels
a little congested
i think that maybe either knight b5 you
know movago or just knight d4
needs needs to have and there it is
knight to d4
and now if we capture we both have iso
the queen's pawns and can i
capture twice on d4 i know it's risky
but the point is if i take with the
bishop
and you take queen takes is thankfully
check to the king
because otherwise bishop h7 would turn
the tables and the queen on d4 would be
hanging so
i guess teddy would play bishop h7 first
and you take and then this happens
after some kind of capture yeah oh i
can't do that there's a queen on c2
i was like wait why is the board not
letting me do that yeah
that's uh would have been the case so
this is the type of idea which
can happen in this position and that's
why lars said let me
backtrack with bishop to d7 and long
story short i think you're correct like
that knight can be taken on d4
but from teddy's perspective i don't
think he had another move
sometimes you go knight d1 to cover that
pawn sometimes your bishop is not on d3
so you can you know move some piece to
d3 to defend e3
but the way the position was there teddy
simply didn't have another move to
defend the e-bomb so he probably said
maybe knight d4 loses a pawn but hey
it's my only option let's play quickly
yeah the thing is when you get rid of
that pawn your bishop on f2 which would
have landed on d4
comes to life so it was a very good
worthy pawn sacrifice for legitimate
compensation and lars didn't take it
especially
look at his clock he's now down to 45
seconds
and that would have been way too easy
for white to play and difficult for him
to play but this position still remains
hard for black
bishop f5 there's no direct threat e6 is
defended d7 defendant
but every single decision like do i take
on d4 is that
committing and helping white in some
regard he says no and we get this
position
yeah um and pawn on d4 the thing with
about these rooks is that
the reason i wouldn't necessarily double
them is because of what is about to
happen right now
they don't look that good on the d-file
i mean hey that pawn's defended but
the bishop on f2 would be sufficient so
i think it's just sort of unnecessary
firepower
on the d-pawn and you almost want to
just shift them one file over either to
c
or the e file so they could be on uh you
know somewhere with a little bit more
scope
absolutely so the rooks are free to move
d5
can't be captured because the rook will
take the queen and then this rook is
hanging on d2
with the bishop here as well but
sometimes you can get walk into
a what looks like a devastating pin but
your knight can move but now
queen a5 is really good by lars here
because if he takes on c3
that's a backward pawn this knight can
come to b6 give me the c4 square
i'm starting to like black's position
agreed uh i think that
uh that's a nice little maneuver uh
queen a5 using the pin
giving me a bishop for night the knight
is going to make an entrance on c4
i do not think that there's any issues
here for teddy
but i think it's the type of position
that could trend in
uh you know black's direction here very
quickly just the knight against the
bishop
is something that you have to be very
conscious of and
teddy's h3 he says uh is that a pawn for
me or does he have some tactics planned
he wants a rookie check but the king hm
queen b1 check that's queen c2 which i
think he probably overlooked
right and this looks powerful yeah now
you have to take and play rook to e7 at
least you win back
uh one of your pawns because queen e1
that doesn't look right
that doesn't look right at all you drop
a2
f7 is hanging and some sort of bishop g3
oh
the bishop's hanging as well is there a
perpetual i don't think so
the knight is too powerful it takes the
c8 square so you get a bunch of checks
but there should not be a perpetual yeah
yeah and
always remember you know queen e6 king
d8 queen d6 knight d7
the knight covers every single checking
square it's just a really thin we're
about to see it
um there you go you can't check anywhere
here as as white
no you cannot and what's the material
count it's a piece for just
one pawn and this a pawn is likely
started gonna start pushing
and becoming a queen but still i don't
think black's fully out of the woods we
know that black should win this game
but whenever your king is susceptible to
checks blunder's admin
yep that's a good point queen a8 um
lots of plays here queen f5 guards the
pawn and threatens queen takes f4 with
checks
makes a lot of sense there and not that
many pawns remain for black so
if you lose your a5 pawn that and
especially because you're both your a5
and b7 that's not going to happen
but then oh goes a5 that's one
yeah and now here come the checks again
yeah that knight is so powerful but uh
king f5 i think that's the right thing
so strong and then that's that right
this pawn is
just pushing and okay seven seconds for
lars
g4 you gotta start pushing your pawns
but it's too slow for
for white here can't play h4 you drop
this pawn
so your pawns are stuck that's the
killer that's the killer you cannot
touch the h pawn so all the pawns
are immobile and uh wow big big result
there as
lars steals the the first couple games
here
in the uh the three-minute portion
yeah and they've been really close
they've been nail biters but in that one
teddy i guess he didn't really sense the
danger i was complimenting him
in the first time show for his ability
to recognize transitions
of in this case it was bishop taking
that knight on c3 and
lars was the one who capitalized but in
the five minute it felt like teddy was
the one who was
trading off simplifying in very powerful
ways so right now lars he's looking
like he's in charge of this match here
and he goes back to his bird's opening
even if some of the games the positions
have been a bit shaky he says
this is my trusty weapon in blitz yeah
and the thing about
this uh the way he's played this time uh
his king's not on e1 and he's not
threatening a quick e4 so
um he hasn't put his queen on the e file
and his king's no longer an e file so
now
e5 does fall victim to not only maybe a
loose bishop on f5 with the rook
but just taking and then following up
with d4 which
would be a fork right which did not work
when the queen was on e2 because the
bishop would be able to take
but the man's point is good the king is
in the corner the queen is safe
so this kind of tactic would well
backfire from black so
teddy's not going to play e5 that's for
sure if you play d4 which is somewhat
tempting
you look at that bishop on g2 and it
opens up on
the diagonal so d4 you break on the
position for your pieces but you really
really
helped that bishop on g2 so i think that
you have to
time that correctly if you play it at
all yeah
and i'm starting to wonder i mean it
looks like an extremely good adjustment
by
lars for something in the middle of a
match uh in the middle of a format
the last time that he played this
opening didn't go that well
and this one suddenly looks a lot better
it does but i'm looking at e5
he went queen e1 which makes e5 possible
again
yeah the thing about e5 is you have to
tell yourself that
your bishop on f5 being defended only by
the rook
on e5 is somehow okay um
and teddy teddy's rationalized because
we've been pointing out that
d4 doesn't work because bishop takes
right that queen being on e1 it's on the
wrong square you wish that if e5
happened your queen could go back to d1
but the queen's here and that's why
chess can be a game of timing things
precisely and right now e5 is very good
for the rook
it's winning that battle with a queen
along the lines e3 square
especially if you take and the e file
opens up this knight can come to g4
later
i think that teddy's just pouncing and
if you look at lars he doesn't look very
happy
no no he's he's barreling down with the
calculations there
e5 i think you generally have to take
this pawn
um after e5 but is he trying to
conduct a way to play like knight h4 f5
trying to keep it closed
i guess and that does keep it closed
uh but then there's those d4 moves that
we talked about hey you called it knight
h4
hitting his bishop so where does the
bishop go
yeah it almost like you know if you go
bishop b6 the f5 move is too
too tempting right it's just gonna
happen immediately um bishop
g4 then h3 happens so i was actually
almost gonna say this
but i i thought i'd let teddy do the
honors bishop to c8 what do you think of
that move
i like it and i think you probably want
to play with like d4 now to open up the
position for your pieces and there he
goes
d4 is played but that gives the e4
square and
lars loves this style of position where
he can play g4 play g5
and that's what he's going for even
though it's not going to happen maybe
for the next
five 10 moves but this is the position
where it's closed down
and he can go what he considers for like
a free attack on the king side
yeah i don't know um if this is the
position that teddy wants because
that bishop on c8 it can't develop and
the knight on d4
can always eventually be kicked out
queen f2 c3 um
and g4 g5 is such a quick easy plan for
white to initiate the bishop one e4 is a
hero
it stops black from playing e4 which
opens up the board
it covers the diagonal hits b7 protects
d3 protects f5
and as we're saying g4 g5 but if you
play g4 maybe there's a quick knight to
d5
and that hits the bishop gives you the
f4 square for your knight so you have to
be careful about these decisions
and i didn't like taking that bishop
honestly because the rook on eight
suddenly
it puts pressure on a2 but it also can
maybe get into the center of the board
by lifting up the a file yeah i think at
some point lars is going to have to
invest into a move like a3
just to play it uh the rook from a1 will
swing over
e1 or d1 and
we might see the move a3 right away
actually followed by
maybe rook a to e1 and then he's gonna
try this king side stuff rook a4 i'm
trying to figure out is there
at some point a threat of rook takes e4
he says no
not for now but bishop takes b7 it
doesn't attack the rook in the corner
so you can play c6 and trap the bishop
there so teddy quickly playing bishop c6
applying pressure on the e4 square this
seems like a good way to get out of
things
yeah and if g4 happens there's always a
long-term idea okay we have to move the
bishop
but bishop c6 fell by knight d5 and then
on d5 gets into f4
so i was thinking something like g4 for
white knight g2
to watch over the e3 and f4 squares um
and then h4 g5 just you know send send
the uh
the king side pawns and well lars starts
the queen
c2 to attack the rook on a4 so bishop c6
would not have been possible because of
the capture so that's why teddy puts
queen on a8 and is he lining up some
kind of bishop c6 if you take to take
with the pawn
and then play c5 like is the queen well
placed
yeah that's weird because if the king
was on g1 you could almost play bishop
takes v7
f5 was hanging oh wow tay didn't notice
the difference like
lars played the move and teddy was
responding instantly to bishop c6
he's learning about you know his time
trouble he needs to play quickly but he
could have taken the pawn and now he's
moving slowly again
and his rook take which is good keep the
tension and maybe go after this d3 pawn
this looks good for black
agreed uh the rook is going to slide
over we might see queen e2 followed by
rook d1
to watch over the d-pawn white needs to
do something but as soon as
g4 gets played that f4 square is looking
juicy that's true
is teddy really trying to play c4 here
that seems
not great if he's next e7 all right and
how does he continue queen b5 where are
the pieces going where do they belong
i don't know i don't know the rook on a4
looks so
strange here it does but the queen on b3
surprisingly a good defender
helping the king cause the queen can
drop back to f7 at any moment
and 10 seconds for teddy he needs to
move yeah and he he knows that knight
wants to get to f4 but g4 g5 when
the time pressure's on that's the
scariest thing to see
and the thing is the black king's in
trouble right so knight takes f6 check
but then teddy may have a quick counter
against his king on g1 it just feels
like white is
dominating right now because this is
such an important pawn in the position
agreed that's me that's such a strong
move it stops queen f7
really really good one there queen h5
have to play rook g8
and king f2 wait that king there's no
checkmate for
white and suddenly this king is in
trouble yeah and the rooks are basically
stopped by these connected pass bonds in
the middle of the board knight knight g6
with tempo take this
take uh the pawns are all falling though
but knight comes that f4
wow what is happening here 94th check
don't mind if i do
okay queen i don't know yeah exactly
queen somewhere we need the queen
involved yeah h3 oh nicer is coming i
guess
there's some sort of checkmates you have
to watch out for the bar is just
going up and down with every single move
and queen before checking h7 where's
the wind king up to h6
oh that pin pin oh no pin is gonna seal
it just take it
and if you want just make make b4 a4
happen
something like that you need to pass
upon
there he goes he's going to play c5 and
a4 wait so but if a4 you play c5 so here
come e4 now c5 win
wait c by b5 what so a4
a4 wins you know a4 wins king d4
wait it didn't like to just take and
then black spawn queens too
and it's check oh my goodness oh my gosh
check so
black is up a pawn and this king is
super advanced
which should help an attack against this
king here what the heck just happened
both players have the same calculating
look right now the hands on the forehead
neither one of them can believe what the
hell is going on i mean i certainly
can't and
queen e2 queen b1 check okay queen back
to e4 i like the queen on e4 the king
yeah yeah exactly
what just happened oh my goodness bring
the king maybe the queen side yeah
i i kind of like this you want to try to
push that pawn here we go king c4
finally
and now king c3 now if you just check
you block with the check those
counter checks are really important nice
c5 here comes the pawn
c4 check on a3 king
okay check your king d3 king e3 just
keep running the king away
you didn't push the pawn gosh the shield
and this
kiss is really good by teddy yeah this
is very impressive play
and now where is the win feels like it's
right there maybe i would throw an h3 he
does
like it because this king is in a mating
net almost 23 and
check when he's
that was amazing i did not i did not
notice that and that is exactly what you
should be looking for
he missed queen d3 check but lars
so so astute how did he see that
oh my gosh it's queen e3 it takes away
all of these squares
and g2 is covered so what a fine
because queen d5 teddy had to play check
here which forced the queen trade wins
the game with his pawn
instead he sees no squares for my king
and that is a stalemate trick if i've
seen one what a swindle at the end there
oh my goodness robert he the thing is he
had to play queen d5
what a wild wild game i mean he there
was queen d3 winning for black but
that's just uh full credit to lars and
we saw the little golf clap at the end
by teddy he was even appreciating
um what his uh what his opponent was
able to do there
well the player is going to take a quick
break they will try to wrap their heads
around what just happened we don't know
but we also will join them in that break
we'll return a few minutes for more in
this three minute plus one second
increment time
segment of this matching international
master teddy coleman and international
master
lars ask for how
[Music]
and we are back ready for more action in
this three minute plus one second
increment time control between teddy
and lars amman that was a wild final
game we saw and
just gotta give credit to lars for
spotting that stalemate trick
yeah and and i mean credit to both
players that was just a really
exciting game because i thought teddy
was down and out i don't know how he
made a comeback i don't even know how he
got a queen on the board robert let's be
clear
uh but both sides got a queen and then
lars with
basically time taking down and i thought
all hope was lost
he plays queen d1 initially i'm like
wait that's a mouse slip
and no that is far from a mouse slip
that is a
completely sick idea yeah well done
there
by lars and you're right that he
actually has outplayed teddy
in these structures where the king side
is frozen white has upon f5
he's been launching his pawns forward
very well but teddy kind of
held him off well and then it got wild
had enough time so
that game is sort of the match some
microcosm for the match at large where
things just get crazy and lars comes out
on top or in this case he survives a
position that
as it wasn't going his way at that point
but really just credits both players for
the fight that we've seen yeah and we've
seen a lead
uh as substantial as the one we
currently have so six and a half to
three and a half
for lars but uh you know previously was
4-1
robert and and teddy mounted that
comeback at the end of the five minute
portion
however we're going to need to see i
think the exact same thing from him
in the uh in the three-minute portion
right now if he wants a chance in the
bullet
and lara's going back to this kind of
delayed benko's gambit
type of position and there's a knight on
e2 which may seem strange
but if this knight does come to g3 the
e4 pawn is extra well defended so teddy
has a choice here
he of course can take on a6 this bishop
can take back and
then we'll see a bishop trade but the
tension remains and this is what we saw
in the
longest time patrol right and uh i kind
of like the
the idea of uh this delayed
uh delayed benko i guess nate on g3
is never the best piece against you know
the g g6 pawn
uh can't really move anywhere it's
mainly there to defend the e pawn
so uh i i think this is totally fine for
for lars and
it's kind of an offbeat opening that uh
seems to play into his play style a
little bit more than teddy's it's gonna
be a wild game
although i think teddy did study this
because in the earlier game his knight
was on
f3 and lars broke with e6 which he's
doing once again
but the big difference is you can take
on e6 and you feel good about your e4
pawn of course
the thing that black would try to do is
play maybe take with a pawn and play d5
but i'm worried about these two pawns
and teddy goes for right away
and i see the eval bar just sticks it
says i hate that
it looks reasonable to me but look at
this this bishop
that's a problem yeah yeah no
the movie e5 is such a natural move
i want to point out first of all like
it's the first move most people think of
you want to ruin black's pawn structure
and take a look
after d takes e5 that would be a
terrible structure like doubled
isolated e pawns isolated apon c pawn
like
everything's a mess but the the style of
the
position that lars has is is that you
can take a structure like that you can
play an active move like knight to d5
um and i think that this is going to
work out tactically
for for lars and lars is just he's
wide-eyed he's like did this really just
happen teddy goes bishop c4 which
i think is a good decision all things
considered but he did it a bit
more slowly than uh you know i would
want to do if i'm playing from the white
side here the bishop on c4 hits d5
it attacks the e6 pawn perhaps with
check behind it but now
i mean this e3 bishop can be captured i
don't really care about the e6 pawn g2
is hanging
it feels bad it does it does because
knight takes e3 it's like if you want to
throw in bishop e6 as a move in between
i think you might regret that g2 is
going to be hanging and the only reason
i take g2
is that you can't castle uh ever right
you don't have an a1 rook and you're not
gonna be able to castle king side and on
top of that e5
is hanging queen h4 is coming up next
queen e7 so i
i just i can see this going really
really poorly for
for teddy yeah that e5 move we
understand it you regret it immediately
and lars
quickly says hey that's a misstep there
buddy and this bishop on g7
very powerful as well the e5 pawn it can
take on d6
at some point or well not anymore
because i just took it but look at that
the evil bar dropped i'm guessing it's
because it gives white a little bit of
time
so teddy can castle here if he wants and
it's not that he's out of the woods his
position still is a bit difficult
but now is king of safe yeah no that's a
really important uh really important
thing to have the uh the king
safe means that teddy can actually play
the rest of this game i was worried
after knight takes e3
f takes e3 that king would be stuck on
e1 robert and just simply would never
get castle for the rest of the game
and now it's safe and sound if you do
take on e3 i will certainly consider
taking e6 with check
and queen a7 we saw sneaky queen a7
in the match between costa and tanya
it's like well
what queen a7 here makes a lot of sense
because i'm attacking your bishop
putting pressure on your knight
and that's why lars just says i'm going
to develop and keep this tension in the
center
with this knight on d5 and everything
staring at it
yeah i mean you got these three pawns in
the middle of the board the bishop on e3
can always be taken and
he started saying look if you want to
save that bishop go ahead uh you know
the knight's pretty strong on d5 i could
take um on e3 but i
don't i don't need to you know i have
like ideas like knight f4 like queen h4
and the knight on d7 might want to
strengthen the center by
you know going let's say knight to b6
from d7 and attacking the bishop at the
same time
yeah those knights are very powerful and
bishop h6 gained a tempo against the
rook
and lars says okay don't mind if i bring
my rook up the bad news about the rook
being where it is bishop takes e6 will
pin and win that rook so this knight and
e4 is a bit stuck for the time being but
you mentioned
knight two b6 coming yeah and i think
maybe like
knight takes c3 and queen h4 might have
been a threat there
hitting the the bishop on c4 and the
bishop on h6 so
i think the queen is going to come out
to h4 like pretty soon or at least it
looks like a
natural square but knight f4 is another
really really uh
a good move aggressive move towards the
king although this is a great response
by teddy here he's keeping it
complicated
bishop takes f4 is a threat because the
e6 pawn is not defended
this queen on a1 is actually well placed
to jump into the queen side if you're
not careful maybe a5
some of that to pin the knight on b6 and
i think it's suddenly
more difficult for black to play even
though i love this bishop on b7
and this knight and for what's the next
move here yeah that's a
great point i think teddy has a
tremendous job in this game because
i have pretty much never liked his
position uh the whole way through
and that's when it's hardest to play
good moves you mentioned queen a7
let's keep that move in the back of our
minds because queen a7 is going to
really hurt lars's position at some
point if he's not careful and he plays
knight d5 which reinforces 994 which is
necessary here to defend his e6 pawn
12.9 seconds left for lars teddy trying
desperately to find a movie is it knight
g5 is it bishop g5
he plays h3 just defending and lars
quickly plays queen eight
the bar doesn't like that queen a5
taking advantage of the queen moving so
what's going on here amman my goodness i
i it's
really really quick here um i think
we're just gonna have to appreciate the
the calculation that these guys are are
putting in uh kind of shuffling back and
forth by lars and
every move by teddy seems to have
purpose i really like what he's doing
so do i look the rook comes in a7 the
queen can come back to a5
and it feels like largest position is on
the verge of falling apart yeah he's
shuffling every single move by lars is
like queen his queen is moved like ten
times
and the bar is just going it means that
black's position was fine at first but
no longer
uh is it approved of here and what do
you do how do you break through for
white
the moves that tay's making look
reasonable and i don't know that rook
takes f7 queen a7 check
yeah okay but what's going on this
diagonal it's connect five no connect
six
wait knight to e6 what's possible
something like that what's happening
i have no idea
the b6 pawn is not quite hanging but
after bishop to e2
it might be yeah there it dropped and
now the queen has to go wait e4 is
hanging wait didn't take a free piece
the 94 was hanging this is too much to
take in here
it really is uh knight after c5 knight
c5 take on e5
you gotta see these tactics yeah oh
e5 is not that nice bishop g4 is coming
g2 is hanging here as well
and 10 times d6 pawn was just hanging
there
i mean that's just the pawn was the
least of the things that were hanging
in that time scramble robert oh yeah
that's
those are just you know at the end of
them you're upset you're annoyed that
you lost the game but you just gotta be
like
that was an utter crapshoot we both had
chances like spinning the roulette wheel
yeah it truly truly was and the the fact
that
lars is able to win the roulette spins
as well as the ones where he's actually
in control
is why this match looks like it's more
out of hand than it is
yeah there was such a weird game e5 as
you're saying it looked logical but then
it got good for black very quickly but
then teddy was being resourceful
and lars was shuffling but doing so
quickly and then lars
somehow prevented teddy from winning
down the queen side
and then finally everything broke loose
and until he lost in time when lars did
have the better position at that point
so oh yeah what is this by the way what
are we walking into now what's this
pawns in g5
i have no idea it looks awful i'm just
gonna say like hey
straight up uh the pawn on g5 there's no
bishop on g7
the dark squares look really really weak
um
i was gonna say is that a mouse slip but
no i guess it's not
knight takes e4 and teddy is
uh going i honestly would have thought
that lars had the black pieces in this
game because
this feels like a more offbeat line that
he would go for
but said teddy's saying i'm down by four
points i gotta risk it to get some wins
here
but now that lars has castles this rook
is staring down at f7
you can win upon c3 have fun with that
pawn your king is never gonna be safe
yeah i i it's very close to some sort of
bishop takes e6
queen over to h5 type of stuff um
the knight takes on f2 hey get rid of
the bishop but now the rook is actually
ready to double up
as soon as that queen moves rook over to
f1 i mean
i think there's just going to be a bunch
of sacrifices here how does black
survive if the knight goes to b6 to gain
gain time and get developed that just
gives white to e5 square and i
i think this could be a really quick uh
win for for lars i am not liking teddy's
position at all
no and bishop b5 played you mentioned
the e5 square he says don't mind if i
hop the pony right there
real soon and i don't mind giving up my
bishop for this knight if it gives me
this e5 square
so do you have to castle king's side i
say that
but like this can't be right you know no
it can't be
but it's it's a this is fine meme you
know just
sometimes you got to go for it 95. oh
this is a disaster
so if you castle short queen h5 king g7
to defend h6
f7 is actually hanging there which is a
really like weird concept because
you're not used to the f file being open
this early
um and uh rook f8 that's like you know
the beginner chess player that tries to
castle and touches the rook first
although he wants to cast a queen side
so if he gets one free move
he will be able to run his king to the
other side of the board and
we're not rooked is rook takes f7 rook
f7 queen h5 but that's exactly it then
you castle and get your king to safety
so
there are tactics that look powerful
perhaps and i'm i'm casting right away
yeah i'm closing my eyes and castling go
and the c3 pawn
is under attack yep and the whole thing
can fall apart
queen takes c3 queen takes d4 uh
what is the thought process here yeah i
was going to say it must be queen take
c3 otherwise
teddy is he wants the castle but i think
he's viewing queen takes e3 as an
opportunity
yeah good inclusion it says my king is
never going to be truly sheltered so
at least i'm getting a pawn for my
troubles once i castle my rook is on d8
protecting my bishop
you can have the f7 pawn i don't really
care about that at this point as long as
my king
feels safe and it will feel much safer
when you castle queenside
and i think rook takes f7 um is a
consideration here
you can throw in that move to start um
because
well he certainly can't take the rook
back and queen takes a1 there's like
rook f1
check kind of a weird move the queen on
h5 delivers the check and the rook then
attacks the queen in the corner
so um there is a rick takes f7
consideration but
teddy can always seemingly just castle
out of that
yes and this rook is hanging this pawn
is hanging with check
bishop e8 is even a threat here to pin
the rook to the queens like
all these tactics could turn in black's
favor and
after rook d1 castle's queen side we see
the evil bar saying okay
white is a bit better and that's
typically scary when
whites down some material but knight f7
then says nope not good
it's funny because i i don't even see
how white's a bit better
this looks like it's falling apart and
very shaky for
for lars and i don't know how teddy did
that that was a terrible opening
but he might even be just better now
wait
the rook's hanging uh i think
four i think you spoke a moment too soon
there
because you want rook takes f2 queen c2
check oh
okay that's actually a good call and so
knight d8
rook f2 king f2 queen takes c2 and this
rook is hanging
right and there's like no way to to stop
it so bishop a4
very like intentional for that tactic it
looks like
okay so where queen e2 was played and
this rook can't go to e8 because knight
d6
check and if the rook goes to d7 still
knight d6 check
and your rook is undefended right
yeah that's that is easy to overlook
that is very easy to overlook because
you think you're the one setting the
traps you know getting creative with
bishop a4 if you're
you're one step ahead but this is
actually such a weird position that rook
just can't move so you got to give it up
so i believe like bishop sees it by the
e6 pawns also hanging with check that's
annoying to make king b8 i don't really
know where else to go
and i want to put my bishop on c6 at the
end of the day so he takes an f7
rook takes f7 and
king b8 yeah so this is this is
reasonable
i think if you were gonna do king b8 you
start with it so the rook's still on f2
in this position but not not really a
big deal because hey he plays rk
rock f2 himself so we're getting the
position that we wanted after all the
bishop on c6 is powerful
but it doesn't threaten anything thanks
to this rook and f2 so i would just take
this pawn he does h6 is falling
and teddy puts king on a7 so he can take
on d4 which was not possible move ago
because queen effect would have been a
check
yep um i like what teddy did though king
is safe he's got a blockade
and he can work on trying to take the
pawns you cannot let c4 d5 happen
um if that happens the game's over yeah
it's an
extra exchange and it was one pawn now
it's even amount of pawns
but this could actually turn around
let's say the coins get traded and this
a pawn starts running
that is not the easiest thing for white
to deal with but when did d3
bishop b5 you were saying you can't
allow c4d5
yeah stop it oof and this is gonna like
i think
yeah i think i pretty much said it like
c4d5 doesn't seem like a big deal
but it kills that bishop's diagonal and
it was perched up nicely
now i think this is just over d67 you
just
push it and the bishop will have to
sacrifice right yes rook takes c4
all right but d7 the end still works you
you've worked f7
to win he's going to go rook back it
needs to be rook c8 here
um it's definitely a valiant try because
you can play b4
and cover with the bishop so uh still in
this game and teddy's maybe two seconds
they both have two seconds i don't even
realize that
now there are two pass pawns and whose
pawns are faster
white is up in cereal this is crazy
running
eight uh before before we gotta go 2.8
seconds barely got that move off
wow 2.6 to 1.5 two points up again oh my
gosh the king is going all the way in
black's going to win this oh no way
bishop b5
wow what do you do here what is this
who's winning my goodness who's winning
and why bishop c4 maybe
yeah bishop d3 okay bishop b1 is an idea
to take on h7
rookie my god what is happening i have
no idea
queen but they i think the king is in
king f6
oh this also works you had a queen here
take on g2 may as well queen d4
check he's got a flag oh my god
they won a time and they both are just
laughing this is like the
fifth time in the match and someone is
lost in time
he's going for the checkmate and he just
loses sight of the clock
it's it's actually hilarious because
rook takes g2
and suddenly as white you almost like
you look around the board you're like
what the hell do i move here
he's like panicking he just literally
could not pick up a piece
and decide where to put it in the amount
of time he had it's also a puzzle rush
situation where you know you're
completely winning
but you want to win instantly because
you're playing in this time scramble so
he looks like the checkmate
and then he doesn't find it and he's
trying to figure out what piece to move
the rook or the queen and he loses on
time
unbelievable unbelievable and lars
lars was looking after that like just
stunned like shell shocked he was just
like
what the what that just happened like he
just got punched just in the face he's
like
dazed and confused but he's gotta play
the next game right away so
uh teddy he's gotta ride that momentum
robert if there's one way to come back
in this match
it's wins like that that is just
bonkers and we get we get back to a
position where you see
the pawn e3 pawn d4 dynamic and the
knights on g6
rather than an e6 so that frees up the
bishop on c8 but it doesn't put pressure
in the center so i actually like this
position
better for teddy than i did the other
one
yeah and keep in mind the pawn on h7 is
different from last time it used to be
pawn h6 knight e6 now the pawn is needed
on h7 to
guard the knight on g6 so um i would say
though that teddy's position is a lot
more stable than last time and i would
yeah i was going to say i would take on
c5
before black has a chance to play c4
yes and well especially with this b5
inclusion
you create some weaknesses and wait a
second if you take on c5
can i move my knight knight takes b5 and
win your bishop there that seems like a
problem
yeah because keep in mind there's like
ideas like knight c7
at the end of that um for example knight
takes b5 bishop e3
knight c7 i think we win material there
right and he plays knight d4 which is a
reasonable choice but he wasn't thinking
tactically and
just to go back a half step here you
were saying bishop e3 knight c7 that's a
fork of the rooks here and white winds
material yeah that looks great
um bishop b6 and now lars i think
i still think teddy's position is is
totally manageable but
look at the ideas for lars knight e5
brook c8
the c4 square the e3 pawn uh now i think
this is
and i think the eval bar reflects it is
a much more even game
after knight b5 wasn't played yes
and the bishop on f1 it's white's pieces
are safe the king is very safe over here
but if you're getting the feeling that
white's playing a bit passively
defensively
and when i see this dynamic i want to
play a4 but of course i can't do that
with the pin down the c file so a4 not
possible
how do i get to your isolated pawn
that's the theme of this opening do i
bring my knight to e2 into f4 it looks
kind of precarious honestly but my e3
pawn is weak but
there are times when you bring the
knight this way he plays bishop h4
losing side of the e3 pawn but gaining
an attack on the d5 pawn
and the first thing that i would think
of is like i have to get my queen out of
the way
so as white i want to move my queen it
just doesn't belong on a file where
brooke is staring it down
so whether that is to make the threat
bishop takes f6 or knight takes d5
or both um you know i'm going to need my
queen out of the way for that
or just to just to move my queen so that
i can actually do something with that
queen i'm not sure from c2 it's the most
operative
there is an idea maybe to throw it over
to f2 and like
g3 um queen to b3 puts pressure on d5
so i would look to get that queen out of
the way even if it's a move like queen
b1
that makes sense and i think a problem
for white is you need your knight in d4
but you also want it off of the d4
square because if it's gone from d4
d5 is under attack there are pins
against this queen but you need it on d4
precisely because of this e3 pawn and
it blockades the isolated pawn itself so
bishop takes you i like that decision
that's a good move to take that and
especially when you take with the rook
you couldn't take with the d-pawn
because you're walking into discoveries
against your queen so the rook takes and
that pawn is still here on d5
as a permanent weakness yeah and it
would be in moments like this where i
would start to punch in
um a lot of moves from white so brook d3
uh i think it's very reasonable rook d1
i think moves like king h1 h3 i feel
like there's a lot of these sort of wait
waiting style moves that's right because
the queen is stuck on d8 you do not want
to allow bishop takes f6
we take with the pawn this queen may be
important defending the d5 pawn
there's bishop on e6 defending the d5
pawn so for black i want to play a5 b4
but then my b5
pawn's hanging so do i just play b4 no
he goes back and
teddy's moves are easy yep yeah and this
is really important
we've seen him come back on the clock
and look at that move king h8
he almost wants to say maybe g takes f6
is gonna be a real
consideration in the future do you think
he's gonna be moving his queen to d6 or
something and
being okay with those double pawns and
it might be an anticipation of queen h4
right because it goes queen e7 and queen
h4 still can be played
trying to take on f6 and double ship
yeah oh
wait why would you take that did he just
forget the move bishop d8 was played
because he's like what
why would you take that he's like well
my bishop now is here and that's all
good
so yeah this is just i mean it's not a
blunder but you know by any stretch but
it's just like a funny decision
to take you know bishop for night
unprompted especially when bishop d8 was
you know the exact counter that
yeah and tennis position is still good
we like the rooks the pawn d5 is still a
problem maybe knight f4 now
makes sense but he's taking his time
he's being deliberate but bishop takes
f6 that's a move you
want to take back i think so i think so
um just no matter what he will probably
want that back um
lars is gonna yeah i was gonna say bring
the king to the middle um
king to e7 and it's hard to add
full pressure to that what is he doing
knight e2 maybe knight c3 ideas but the
counter attack comes with rook c2
yeah the bishop on f6 right the bishop
that he gave up there
and now it's playing its role and b4 is
a good move because
a3 is a bit more difficult to get to but
bishop b2 could have been played there
it say takes on d2 and now you can't get
to this pawn and d5 is under attack
yeah wow this looks like a a miss if
king d6 there's just
e4 or knight takes d5 and e4 um
and you're just going to pick off that
pawn and so lars says
take me i'm going roxy too at the end of
this entice
okay go rook c2 that's good for you
brings the rook back to d3 protects here
but
bishop b2 no bishop b2 walks into rookie
too so bishop b2
will not be black's next move or it
should not be so white can you play f4
king f3 and get the pin big fan of f4
the reason being that the king is going
to then access a light square
which stays off you know the dangerous
uh dangerous squares that could go
through i think h3g4
makes a lot of sense here e4 loses
immediately
in each form i'm not sure i'm a fan of
that and i'm definitely not a fan of
that you take with the pawn and the king
comes in
that was just a really honest rook here
robert do you
do you take with the right i think i
have a problem with the rock take with
the rook and you make a draw he does
that yeah
rook d8 and just start going around
after black spawns
yep seven seconds though and you gotta
move and he's probably frustrated as
well
black can start you know after rook a8
go king d5 king c4
and just go for that win and he
backtracks the rook b6 is now rook b7
check and if the king goes to g8
maybe there's an opportunity somehow for
white to play for moore and yeah
wait terrible move wait was it what
uh that's that's gonna be i think it's
gonna be a win for black now
um still very drawish but it just feels
like
decision after decision is not going his
way oh and he put his king here
and this pawn's hanging no this has been
many many
incorrect decisions here yeah oh
with a pre-move the pre-move and lars
just laughs and teddy can't believe it
well especially because in some ways
like rook takes f4 was the
the easiest move to anticipate from
black so lars is probably like hey you
know you're not sneaking that one by me
um he takes that one that one back and
robert what a conclusion to the to the
three minute portion here because
i i think we saw a sign of hope maybe
uh on teddy's side with that insane win
on time
and lars winning the last game in the
segment just to you know
make sure that things aren't getting out
of hand yeah and to make it matters
worse for
teddy he was up a clean pawn in that end
game right he had
an extra pod that bishop was the hero
for black the one that he ended up
taking on f6
and then the bishop went to a1 and then
took this knight on d4 so
some poor making there but also
it's tough you're in the middle of a
battle you're down three games you need
to win
you're putting pressure on yourself and
he did see that d5 pawn is a permanent
weakness so i get why he did it
unfortunately for him it didn't actually
get him the point and in fact he
lost the game he really had no business
losing so for lars
eight and a half to four and f i'm on
before we take a break what advice can
you give the players heading into bullet
well um for teddy basically uh
play a little bit outside your play
style outside your comfort zone
make decisions you wouldn't normally do
look to play as fast as possible as
loose
as possible and just know that you might
have to shift up
your playstyle to get wins because you
need to make up a four-point difference
i like that advice we'll see if
teddy heats it in the meantime we're
gonna take our last break and we get to
the bullet portion
of this i'm not gonna speed this
championship match brought to you by
chess.com
[Music]
and just want to remind everybody that
you can get involved you can play in
arena kings season six
is well underway mondays and fridays
anyone can play
only streamers can win but it's a fun
time you can play the likes of
well-known grandmasters other streamers
who are you know
making their greatest efforts to take
down those prize funds
it's been a lot of fun has it not yeah
it really has and i i was just thinking
because
uh hicaro is playing in a tournament
right now is this like is this
everyone's chance to maybe actually win
first place for once
we'll see if he sits it out he is
playing in the champions chess tour but
that's a good point maybe now i'm more
encouraged to play honestly
exactly there we go well before we get
to arena kings of course we have the
final segment of this match we have
teddy coleman
down four points against lars oscar hogg
you gave advice
you're saying what teddy needs to do he
needs to mix it up play quickly
get positions that are not expected and
for lars honestly keep doing what you've
been doing you've been playing
good chess you've been finding the
accurate moves in time
trouble and that's been i think the
biggest difference in this match is
throughout the games it's been back and
forth but then we get to the time
scrambles and feels like lars
has had the upper hand but then again he
did lose that game on time
a couple of games ago up a queen yeah
it's almost like
uh both players are totally capable of
losing on time which is why i think that
teddy
needs to be comfortable playing um
playing these crazy crazy positions and
trusting himself a little bit more
that's what bullet's all about instincts
and uh we're gonna see if he has what it
takes
robert in the bullet portion because if
he makes a comeback in this match it's
gotta be in the bullet portion which is
not
where where i think teddy would normally
expect to score his points
no the position is so closed right now
and bishop takes e5 you couldn't take
with the knight because the pawn would
have taken
and said we're just getting a series of
trades c5 is
on the agenda here i would push that get
my queen to b6 this feels like the type
of start to a game that teddy wants but
lars
to his credit he's keeping things closed
then how do you win a game from the
black side of this
yeah i was gonna say like not only is it
maybe a start that teddy wants
it's definitely a start that lars wants
he's got two bishops
i don't really see a dangerous plan for
black
of course there's lots of plans but
there's nothing really that he has to be
concerned about so
he can build this up slowly um i don't
think
that lars is going to be unhappy with
what he's got in game one here
i guess in a sense i have my classical
chess hat on where like black is doing
fine this is the exact type of position
you want
you've neutralized white's opening
advantage but you're writing bullet it's
so frustrating this bishop on h2 just
sits here and covers the length of the
diagonal
you attack my pawn on b2 i just protect
it good for you
but i like this transition here if you
can get this knight to c4 maybe you can
start
causing some problems for white yeah and
that knight on d6 of course can be taken
but i think lars is looking to keep
pieces on the board
uh really like what teddy's doing from a
positional point of view
but keep in mind while you're playing
everything on the queen side
uh h4 h5 and lars is striking on the
king side
and that's why teddy brought the queen
back b5 wasn't really the main idea it
was allowed the queen access to the king
side to help out
so queen f6 queen f5 offer a queen trade
the knight on c4 is very strong
but time is taking amman we've already
spent two minutes on this game
and it looks like a position that will
last at least another couple
agreed agreed um queen f5 is a good idea
and he's going to take that followed by
you know ideas like h5
ideas like b3 i think this is exactly
what
lars is looking for although from a
tactical point of view if you can get e5
in from black or maybe even g5
you feel like you're making progress in
the position the knight on c4 is a great
piece
and type is rook a8 and a3
that's just it just hurts the little
part of me there robert when i see the
move a3
basically giving up on b3 as a move for
the rest of the game
and teddy he plays rookie seven he wants
to open e5 i think you have to play
three five yep there it is there it is
and the king can even come to e6 just
this knight
protects and attacks a great position
for teddy with the black pieces
yeah and i think he's like tempted by e4
here but he's worried about how he wins
the game after doing that
because it's hard to find a break right
locking up the position probably not
great so he goes rook c8 trying to rook
h8 and can i just win this pawn
okay now e4 ideas are attempting he does
it he has a
pass pawn protected by another the
knight on c4 dominates his bishop 1c1
so how to win this game though that's
the essential question right i think i
think it has to be g6 so the rook on d7
probably rook d8 rook g8 or rook h8
followed by g6
that makes sense you need to break open
this position because
that's why look at this rook on f2 and
f1 you cannot play g6 otherwise you drop
this pawn so maybe knight d6 would
reroute the knight or rook f1
oh he doesn't play it but this is great
for teddy he now has a of
protecting and attacking g4 is falling
so you can take it but then rook takes
f6 and rook takes f7 that'll be blunder
he starts with king e7 for that reason i
think we just need to guard the pawn
um okay take on g4 is possible now but i
was thinking like
96 98 almost he just trades right he
says my past pawn is too strong
and if the rooks trade this game is over
oh yeah and even if the rook's on the
board this knight comes to c4 and the
king is cut off ooh
rook f6 great move yes well done here
rook f2 e3 rookie two it doesn't quite
work
so he checks the king to hr rook g1
bring that rook around to b1 and thank
you for your b-pawn
yep and keep in mind that pass pawn is
still
going the distance oh no
that's a root blunder oh you got five
we continue to play the game are there
still chances for black here
i think there's still chances it's crazy
black is better the evil bar says black
is better
how is that oh my gosh e2 is coming
what and then before taking knight c4
oh my god knight c2 would have been nuts
wait he's still in this game
okay one rook one and it's just not in
time one move too slow
you should resign you gotta get the next
game going oh my goodness
that's how dominant his position was he
blundered a full rook and he still he
gave him an
entire room and was actually still
winning that's
insane that's hard to do that is hard to
do
and we get a new game here lars now up
five points and playing this kind of
like
dutch-like position in the english we
play pawns f5 and e4
and his knight on h4 it'll continue to
apply pressure on this pawn on f5
yeah i was going to say after d3 i've
seen some lines where they take on d3
and you just go bishop g2 like you just
or bishop h3 like you're just going
quick quick development
um so and i almost think you maybe need
to play
in a little bit of that style uh maybe
not that move but that style because
another game dropping it's just it's not
like you're
one game away from you know one game
further away from the result you want
it's it's even more than that it's the
time invested in that game as well so he
really has some ground to make up
definitely and the knight comes back to
gm lars is playing the most passive
position but he's like come on man
beat me show me that you can win this
game and it looks terrible for black
this knight can come to d4 into c6 or e6
things like that if you take on d4 well
then i get the whole diagonal
knight f4 knight d4 one of these knights
has to move into the position
but teddy's spending time and he only
has just under 19 minutes to catch up
yeah i i really think knight d4 from f3
was
was the way to go you should try to
avoid trades a bit as
um as teddy here because lars does not
have a lot of
squares to put his pieces i would go
knight g5
and say take one of my knights but then
my bishop on b2 shines
so instead he doubles in the e file also
looks good but knight g5
is what i'm looking at and if knight e4
are you
uh considering sacking moving the queen
i'm surprised 84 hasn't been tried yet
well it might happen now just to close
on the e file and try to win this e6
pawn
so not offend that bishop takes f6 and
knight to d4
protect your past pawn put your knight
here then i can come to b5 and that rook
is in danger on a7
yeah this bishop is so strong at g2
knight b5 the rook has to go to a6
there's also knight c6 which forces the
blockader away
i like that so knight c6 is still
probably good because you can't take on
e6 there will be a bishop d5 at the end
with a pin
yeah big fan if you want to play pizza
oh knight d3 okay maybe it's not a big
deal
um but knight d3 is there but now the
queen will replace the knight
and it's hard to dislodge okay he
finally plays knight d3
yeah it's like it's about time and yet
white still has a
pretty decent position but how do you
win this
dude this is like the theme teddy is
look at that rook on a7 robert teddy's
just blundering material
and still winning that's the theme so
how does he actually win this right like
yep i think you need to get your queen
to d7 somehow like
bishop b5 queen c6 queen d7 but i don't
think you have time to do that
maybe i don't know bishop d5 okay step
one
now but the c pawn can move the rook is
out of prison if he wants to yeah and he
takes that chance but he gives up b6 and
that's
maybe not the most important pawn but
look at the time
that's a bullet decision though his work
is free that's counter play
and look at the time it takes four
seconds yeah
rookie three you have to and then rook
d3
go after this d6 pawn i feel like ted's
position is good but 3.8 seconds
not a lot of time obviously yeah black
can try to set up a swindle here like
some sort of uh rookie like as soon as
queen f6 queen a1 happens
man everything starts to fall apart yeah
the queen is an e7 like
that's the move you want to play we have
the past pawn
so king h3 oh no he lost the pawn
you need that thing to win that's the
one you needed
and it's still fine for teddy it's still
good it should be seven oh my gosh the
rooks were in like they couldn't defend
each other
but c6 is pawn is still great he's still
with c7
push that thing push it keep pushing it
still winning wait no the other rook
takes and the a1 queen my god
okay now he's losing actually but it
should be a draw
um yes terrible result though because
this is going to be played on for a
while
just go bishop e6 bishop f7 the king is
actually caught in the corner
this game is going to continue for
another minute i would play g5 yeah
exactly
okay i would actually play like 49 moves
and then play g5 but yeah
to each their own yes and teddy should
throw in a g7 like if he anticipates a
pre-move
and he's still not losing if he plays g7
so the bullet thing to do
is just play g7 hope that lars is
pre-moving on your queen
the problem with g7 is that um didn't
they repeat that position like 20 times
by the way
the problem with g7 is that if you play
it and your opponent catches you
he's no longer going to give you a draw
like if i if i catch my opponent trying
to get me with the g set it's like okay
hang on
we're playing like that well enjoy the
next 150 moves of this game
that's right because the 50 move counter
starts again and then you make another
pawn move
starts again and that's a problem so we
do have this
um london type setup thingamabobber but
then f3 and g4 so it's like the juvenile
london
yep exactly jabal london the the idea is
a very quick
king side expansion and you know you
play like bishop d3
knight ge2 or nate h3 and then hits f4
right and if that knight gets to f4 that
bishop doesn't feel very comfortable
even on g3 it's strong you play h5 at
any moment you castle queenside that's
what white's going for
but this is the type position you
probably are happy about if you're teddy
because you need to win games
so at least absolutely there's
double-edged nature and c5 is coming
no this this is a good position to have
for the match situation you mentioned
long castling
that's the idea but first e4 and taking
the space everywhere it seems like he's
playing in the center he's playing on
the king side
and teddy does not want to castle on the
king's side
so he castles long and this d4 pawn a
long term
potential weakness knight b6 coming to
c4
okay i pop that pony right into c4
because rook d7 rick did he's playing
this
pretty well he is i also like to move g5
for white
um takes take with the h pawn rook comes
down to h7
and that g pawn just kind of annoying
and takes the f6 square away from black
yeah that's a good idea and knight a2 he
wants to go c3 to defend the pawn i
still want to play knight c4 but i
understand the white queen will then
just run over the to the queen side so
knight c1 e5 not d5
don't like this now the other knight
goes to a7 first one a2 now a7
yeah because what's gonna happen is c4
that is
looking good knight d3 and i like
white's position
yeah all of a sudden white's making
progress but the knight is the best one
strange now oh an a6 oh
gosh you saw it coming yeah and
i think uh e4 with defended knight is
great blockading on d6 but
you know you're down material this is
not this is not enough no
and queen d4 rook d2 nice move go after
the king side pawn somehow then he's
going after g4
and e4 still intense take that and take
with the pawn i think
i take it yeah at this point like queen
g5 is the more positional move but i
think you just had to take with the pawn
and start pushing
yeah take on e4 with the oh there's yeah
maybe you could take on e4 there
yeah i would take on e4 i would almost
still take on e4 but 96
96 96. that's
and that's a full rook by the way
and by the way i didn't look at this but
lars's bullet rate is 2800 and teddy's
is under 2400 so
i think that going into the match both
players knew what would happen
in bullet that lars is the heavily
favored player yeah
and and that's why i was saying when
you're getting the bullet now you know
you're the underdog on paper you're also
the underdog in this match because
you're down
uh going into this i think it was four
games so you really just had to play
totally outside your your style and
comfort zone um if you wanted a chance
and that's what teddy's trying for he
put his bishop on the long diagonal but
you don't want to block the check with
your bishop here and look that's another
check
if queen e2 there's knight takes d4 par
probably so
yep at least ideas revolving around that
so that's a bad thing
this is bad already teddy's got to move
his king to f1 i think
that's no good and black castle so lars
i mean he's been impressive i have to
say
that in the later portions of the three
minute
and then now on the bullet he's really
just said i'm taking this match
i am you know i threw away a couple wins
by losing a time you threw away a couple
wins by losing on time
but ultimately i feel like i've been
playing good chess so let me
take this match and not even let you
back in it and credit to lars for sort
of identifying a win condition
um he's done that in a bunch of his
matches so far he hasn't been like
insanely impressive in five minutes um
but when it comes down to the end of the
three minute getting into the bullet he
really starts to turn on the jets
and he knows he's a very accomplished
bullet player
that he can he can take home victories
in that portion alone
that's true and he brings his knight to
h6 over here just saying no knight g6
for you that could have been a problem
for the king on h8
but now the king walks away and teddy's
position he's still a pawn
he has to take on e8 and so he's up a
pawn but the king on f1
that king is in trouble and it's because
the rook can't get in the game so easily
bishop e4 after g3 um
it looks crushing although
do you have enough time to somehow yeah
knight f7 is strong that's a problem
very good move
got a sack for that you have the e6
square for your knight but you're down
in exchange so
and just like you know the the way that
lars plays bullet
um he's up like 40 seconds it's insane
um teddy is just under tons and tons of
pressure game after game
he is and lars has been great on the
clock with the exception being those
couple games that we've mentioned
a number of times now and teddy look at
him he just planted a knight on e6
and he's had his fair share of chances
right he yes
even one as you said he blunders and
he's still better or still even
he wanted a full rook in that bullet
game
yeah that was that was great that was
basically the the the pinnacle
i think b4 by black needs to happen
there was queenie one check to take on
f2 and that's why
right that's a good point so they
brought it it's always annoying eh when
you when you notice your opponent's
tactic and you're like oh man well
that's not fair they didn't see it
right and this is still bad now no extra
pawn for white
an extra exchange for black and time is
coming off the clock i think it's
already too late we're under 10 minutes
yeah that's definitely too late
and lars six point lead is this match
gonna end with like an eight-point
spread
it definitely could i think uh i think
at this point oh
knight d3 a tricky guy yeah
good effort but drops another pawn rook
f3 can happen or queen f3 and he just
wins on time yeah and he's i think now
is the reflection
part of the the match for teddy where
he's probably thinking about all those
like
miss chances and flags and just things
games he wishes he had back
yeah you know what i hope i hope we see
just fun openings game after game the
match is already over so we have a
you know a king's gambit type of
position here we go g5
g3 trying to break open this pawn
structure and this is a fun one all
right i'm happy about this
yep and we have the vienna uh it is a
fun opening so
i think we're gonna be i think we're
gonna be treated to a good one here
uh the time actually is a lot closer
let's look at lars he's staying close to
a minute on the clock
he's just in the flow he's on he
understands his positions very well
whether it was those games where he
pushed us upon f4 in first move and
later to f5
close down the king side and just put
pressure on teddy or he has these gambit
openings where he's having a lot of fun
he has been doing very well in the clock
yeah we can take on g5 but i was going
to say that lara's move is to castle
um don't even bother calculating that
castle king b1 knight d5
and start to start to again feel that
flow that bullet flow
you couldn't pay me that blocks position
here you're up a pod but you can't move
anything
you can't move anything and like
terrible d
uh d5 knight d4 we know how these games
go
h5 then is under attack e6 is mine f5 is
mine and
here it comes i think he's about to do
knight d4 and as you mentioned
he's going to trade those light square
bishops and that's going to open up
all those light squares like e6 f5 and
everything for the taking
no fun none at all and you also will
have a hard time casting queen side
because your king will still be under
attack once it gets there
so lars is under half a minute so is
teddy about even the clock
but the position feels easier to play
for white it definitely does knight c4
though
um seems like a miss
yeah it's the queen and the bishop was
under attack a second time you got to go
knight c4
you really don't have any other moves
yeah
because the king literally can't castle
in either direction so he goes king of
seven it just wasn't
i mean now a second time yeah okay
both players are just completely
overlooking that possibility
yeah yeah knight c okay there we go he
covered it
yep and that probably when you see b3
happen when you're playing
oh come on why'd you play b3 because i
had knight c4
exactly and now lars is locking down the
queen side and there's a king on g6
which is
not that unsafe but three seconds e3 and
then queen takes a4 for the fans
oh my gosh the bishop one d8 is just
doing a hero's piece of work here
covering f6 covering c7 but it's also
just terrible
look at teddy he's a rookie jade for a
cage seven he's like i don't care
anymore
maybe i'll play h4 you know maybe he'll
try to get a pass pawn
he's literally shuffled his rooks for
like every single move
[Laughter]
that's great why did you just go king a3
pawn b4 trying to win on the queen side
yep the thing is the shuffling
you know it doesn't help the match clock
it's not like he's still thinking about
winning the game of course but
just funny that lars is probably like he
maybe he's not checking the match clock
he's like oh what the
hell i'll do this strategy and well don
goes g3
so who's king is gonna be worse levels
and the king of g6 is surprisingly
okay wait there's two rooks hitting the
three pawn
wait none of eight let it be oh black
guy
and does he see it he finds it yeah
and he's laughing at himself for like
basically how long that took
yeah and teddy's just like what can a
guy do what can the guy do
we still have five minutes and so let's
just have some fun
in the bullet i'm hoping for teddy's
last game
that he plays knight f6 on move one and
rook g8 on move two
that's what i'm looking for you think i
think i'm joking we might see it
is that a is that a teddy special it's
not a teddy bear it's something that
i've wanted to try and i mentioned
it to teddy and so i think that if he
you know is in
good spirits he's having a good time he
might play nine or six or g8
this feels like a good spirits match
like you know it's very competitive but
once both players
kind of get in that zone where it's out
of hand i think it has been pretty
uh good good spirits uh the whole time
you know even
some of the blenders we've seen it's
almost like both guys are kind of
laughing
at the blunder when it happens on the
board yeah when you you look back on
this match
lars deserves to be the winner based on
what we've seen
and for teddy it's like well i was in
most of these games and
it's just a couple things going my way
it's much closer
so for both players there's a mutual
respect here and they're still
playing some serious games down the
stretch this position here locked up
this bishop on g7 very happy the bishop
one f4 not quite as powerful so i like
black's position
yep b6 is gonna just say you know
solidify the entire queen side c5 square
belongs to black
um you know white has some squares nate
knight on d4 and i don't d5 but i
i agree i definitely prefer lars's
position and that a pawn is going to be
picked up and hang on you're also
threatening to win a piece bishop d4
yes the bishop on e2 there was a forks
on the b3 square
and now queen f6 you can win oh you can
just take on b2 right away i guess but
had that as a possibility so he didn't
take this pawn that was
yeah maybe knight b3 to d4 um
b6 is a again i would take on that e3
honestly
he does you don't need to tell him twice
the sacrifice material
yeah look at this bishop on e2 just such
a bad piece
this night this is just good uh chess as
well like rookie three it's
literally a rook for a bishop but
believe me in a classical chess game
some of the top grand masters in the
world would not only maybe consider that
move but probably
play it it's good for black 94
in knight g3 check and black is just
better white has no moves you're stuck
nothing to do take on it i like knight
g3
and queen oh you're that's you're an
evil evil man
that's the way to do it e3 is hanging b2
is hanging
pick which one you want this makes sense
and bishop d4 is about to win the game
there it is that's game yep
so will teddy play knight f6 rook g
that's what i'm looking for
yeah this next game is his chance
there's no way he thinks of that
at this time yes yes he will
have faith wait wait there's a trick
like b6
and then trying to to win here but it's
not going to work
just you can take and then rook takes
bishop and your rook comes back to
defend oh nice try though if rook takes
the spawn takes b7
oh that was clever yeah
but now it's too much extra material
with two minutes of remaining
the next game will be our final one okay
all right here it is
here it is here it is come on teddy
made f6 for the fans depends what lars
plays
one time all right teddy do it oh [__]
it was so
perfect for that oh it was a prime
situation
oh i'm so disappointed that's what i'm
gonna bring up to him first
oh yeah forget everything it's like
where was knight f6 rook g8 you choked
at the end man
oh my gosh i'm just so upset now if
there wasn't such a fun match to not
end on the rook g8 note although what's
with the white's pawn structure now
this is pretty ugly with two sets of
double pawns
yeah in the fact that e5 is not even
your square like i can play
f6 and kick you straight out of there
and then the knight would have to go
back to g4
so for now it's you know f6 would be a
problem with e6 square but it's an idea
to kick that piece out for sure
instead voluntarily brings the knight
back
so if i keep just sort of avoiding
trades if i give white a few free
it goes back to e5 well we did see a
game where teddy moved his rook
like 25 times in a row true
and we saw the game where lars was
defending where he went like rook f7
rook d7 queen b8 like
queen back and forth so we've had a lot
of shuffles and isn't black just
doing so well here he is but
uh g4 i was going to say expected g4 the
funny thing is
f6 traps tonight then oh my gosh you
need the square for your knight
yeah good call yeah i would have played
g4 and blunted my knight there for sure
it just makes sense you're taking away
the f5 square from the knight
and teddy playing some principal chess
queen a5 off from the trade your pawn
structure is better
knight to b8 where's that guy i would
like punch in knight
g5 type of stuff and say look you can
win my night maybe with f6 but i think
it's almost time to sack because look
at the invasion on the queen side by
teddy yeah i'm with you i think that
sacrificing was the best chance for
white because look at king h1
your moves are just shuffling back and
forth and teddy
bringing some more pressure knight to b5
comes to mind to go to the c3 square
potentially
play rook c8 and play c5 you don't want
to undouble the pawns but you can do so
if you
gain something and g4 is g4 though i
like it i mean
if you're going to try something this is
the right thing to do and all of a
sudden
the e pawn and look how quickly the
energy just shifted away from the queen
side
right and that's in very smart move rook
to e3 protecting this d3 pawn so that
you didn't walk into
a loss knight c3 can you grab the a2
pawn
yeah but then then i think maybe f5 and
counter play look at that knight on e2
they're stuck
they're stuck your best move would be
someone move your first knight and then
move your second one out but
the knights are trapped here and b5 you
said f5 there's knight five as well that
could be powerful
because the rook is not defended look at
that i love that uh idea just
give up the a2 pawn and say look your
knights are so silly they do
they support each other but neither one
of them can move yeah it's one of those
situations where it's quality rather
than quantity
black is up a pond but look at the
quality of the pieces and oh my gosh
this king is about to be in a world of
hurt
look at those two knights black king is
probably like wait don't don't i have a
pair of those somewhere on the border
yeah over here buddy um b4 and a2 not
really helping you and knight takes up
six
yikes oh there's gonna be some sort of
puzzle rush finish here yeah rookie
seven queen h6
yep okay queen queen jade's mate so now
it's no longer made
it's me queen
and teddy is just reacting like all the
emotions just you know came to fruition
there at the end
and both players sigh of relief uh
you know i think both players are
relieved that the match is over
they for sure are we'll hear their
thoughts in a few but ahmad just to
summarize this
in the bullet it felt like it was about
to be a close match it had been to this
point
and lars ran away with it so going
forward for him
it feels like he has the right recipe to
keep winning these matches
yeah it looked like lars basically
played the same opening with both
colors that is what happened today he
played the dutch and the
white dutch so so that's all he needed
and he relied on his bullet skills and
at some point
you know i feel like we were just being
treated to the lars show when he
finished with a 10
point differential one of the biggest
margins that we've seen in the entire
competition
well we'll be back in a few we'll hear
the players thoughts in the meantime
grab some popcorn and we will hear
from teddy and lars in just a few
[Music]
so
and welcome back robert and myself are
pleased to be joined by the players from
today's match that's teddy coleman and
lars oscar how
welcome guys and i'll start with you
teddy i mean
a rollercoaster match in the end the
score was reflective of a pretty
convincing victory
by lars but is that sort of how the
match felt to you because
from our perspective there were a lot of
really close games
yeah i i um you know i think definitely
there were a bunch of games that were
kind of pretty tight and and
went okay until we hit the time scramble
and then i think
you know lars is just way too good at
bullet and and and playing under
pressure and
it felt like nearly every single one
broke his way and so
you know congratulations on the win it
was
uh it was a lot of fun uh even though it
you know didn't quite go my way this
time yeah and lars on your end of things
you were up four to one
and then teddy won two games in a row
did that tilt you a little bit did you
feel a bit nervous or
what was going through your mind at that
point uh
yeah it was a bit unfortunate because at
first i thought that like
the match was going really well and then
after i lost those two games
like the score is almost even after
after a three-point lead but
like i that i would do it better in the
bullet section
so i just hope that i would do like fine
in the two blitz sections and then
do well in the bullets and i i got a
lead after the blitz
um the blitz part which was great
yeah that's a good a good strategy and i
guess one that you've been using
very effectively in the entire
competition uh
teddy back to you because there were
some insane time scrambles you touched
on them
uh i can think of a few off the top of
my head where
robert and i were going crazy because
you you blundered like a whole rook
and that the evaluation bar was still in
your favor uh there was one game you
blended a whole rook and you had these
pawns and a knight and
we were like just going going that so
there are so many games where i felt
like you blundered yet
you were still in the game that's how
good your positions were
yeah i think that maybe was the first
bullet game and like you know i played
i think it was rook h2 and he could take
and i was like oh my god
um but then i realized like my key my
king was pretty far advanced and i was
like okay maybe there's some way
um but i couldn't you know i think again
i blundered a little bit later on and
couldn't quite hold it together but um
no there definitely were chances i just
i just didn't seem to be able
to kind of capitalize on them yeah on
the flip side lars you found
that stalemate trick at the end of the
three minute portion which was
unbelievable
just recognizing that with no time on
your clock so between
finding these tactical resources but
also we thought you played really well
when you would put your pawn from f4 to
f5 and close the king side so was that
part of your match strategy overall this
kind of closed positions that allowed
you to
go and try to attack um
i generally try to get like attacking
positions
so i don't really mind if they're open
or closed i just want a position where i
can attack and play actively
so um with the f4 f5 i thought it made
it easier to attack or at least
maneuver for some time and then his king
might be
weeks so at some point
but generally the strategy was just to
create attacking positions i didn't
really mind
if they were open or closed yeah um
i think those are positions that's right
yeah i just think yeah those positions
are also just very easy for you to play
because you just kind of like throw the
g pawn attack my king and
it's like a little bit hard for me to
like generate that um counter punch on
the queen side
so yeah i think it was working really
well for you mm-hmm
the like speaking of f4 f5 i guess was
that
a match strategy lars that you were just
going to play the dutch like no matter
what color you got
yeah but i've played a lot of birds on a
lot of dutch where i
usually go for like this landing ground
uh positions but
uh it worked very poorly with black in
this match
like he played this d4 and then like
early bishop g5 which i
i ended up struggling but i thought i
got good positions when i played it with
white
because then this early bishop g4 isn't
possible
or it's not that good at least yeah i
had prepared this line with f3 which i
only got to play once
but uh you know objectively speaking i
don't think it's a very good line but i
think it just leads to kind of
interesting positions for blitz but
i was hoping to play it again but you
never gave me a chance
yeah i i hadn't seen it before and you
played it so fast so i didn't want to
repeat
well teddy speaking of questionable
lines interesting for blitz
what about knight f6 followed by rook to
hit you had the perfect situation in the
final game
i didn't go for it i know well at that
point you know
uh i know that's your favorite line uh
to try to go d4
knight f6 c4 rook g8 but i saw
you know in the match against selena i
think after d4 knight f6 you were
playing either bishop g5 or something
like that and then
you know then i wouldn't be able to play
it so i don't know
mass disappointment in the commentary
booth
robert was livid that he didn't see rook
g8 at the end
yeah uh wow but that was an entertaining
match uh lars
you um congratulations it was a very
convincing win in the end
uh in one of the biggest margins we've
seen um in the tournament and
you move on to the next round and uh you
know you
you'll be facing off against uh looks
like roberto molina
so uh any any thoughts on that match
upcoming have you seen any of his
previous matches in this tournament
yeah i saw his match versus lauren's
trent
that was quite an interesting one like
trent was ahead
at the beginning i think if i remember
correctly
yeah so that was a very interesting
match
so i'll probably have to prepare a bit
for the movie in the arch
no seems like you're you seem pretty
tired right now i'm not gonna lie
do you feel exhausted after playing
blitz and bullet for three hours
yeah yeah i do
[Laughter]
honest answer yeah well we definitely
appreciate you both joining us lars
congratulations teddy
sorry that your terms come to a close
but for the second consecutive year you
made your presence felt so you should uh
hold your head high
thanks robert all right thanks guys
thank you and we will let lars get off
the bed it's
probably pretty late there uh in norway
and we see that the bracket
is filling itself out lars oscar hogg
moves on to face roberto molina
so amman based on what you've seen today
based on what we saw from roberto
against lawrence
who's the favorite in that matchup wow
it's a really good question
um such contrasting styles like
there's like maybe not a bigger style
clash in the whole tournament
uh roberto molina uh when we were
commentating that match it's like
can i trade these queens off if so i'm
doing it immediately
and lars is probably the exact opposite
energy so
i'm really excited for that match up i
think that styles you know they say
styles make fights
styles make matches so i'm i'm really
excited for that and
also excited robert to find out our our
final
uh our last semi-finalist
yeah we have the match-up tuesday night
that is 6 p.m pacific time that's 9 00
p.m eastern
if you're in europe you can do a quick
little google search to figure out what
time that is for you but you will not
want to miss the matchup on tuesday it
is
international master levy rosin better
known as gotham chess taking on
i am rosen that is eric rosen so i'm on
our time today for this match is done
but you know we've had so much fun today
and
of course is ribbing teddy he is one of
my best friends for full disclosure
teddy and i are super close
and we actually have talked jokingly in
the past i had thought about playing
knight of six rook g8
so i was trying to you know pass the
torch on to him here
he didn't do it but he uh you know he
played a tough match
lars did seem like the better player
between the two in the blitz and
throughout the whole match
lars was just digging deep when he was
in trouble and when he had the advantage
it felt like
teddy couldn't find his footing so i
felt maybe 10
points is more than we expected but it
did feel like the
match went heavily in largest favor
especially down the stretch
yeah and he's uh developing a recipe
shall we say
for for victory because he's used a very
similar style he's he's using the clock
to make up for his bad positions which
is a great strategy in blitz you're not
going to get a good position
every single game you play that's just
not how it works so he's making sure
that when he's in those tough spots
he's playing quickly and then he's using
the clock as a weapon
at the end of the game to at least make
a comeback and if you win
20 30 of the games that you're lost in
and you convert all the ones that you're
ahead and that kind of feels like that's
how this match went today
yeah just that stalemate i'll never
forget that one yeah the quick
queen d5 check which should be paired by
that
queen block and winning the game for
teddy find that stalemate with no time
on your clock that's very difficult
because our instinct is just
keep checking with our queen and do
something but not give it up for free so
that's of course
that was a huge moment in the match
because teddy was trying to
uh decrease his deficit and all of a
sudden lars found the saving move
it probably put teddy in a bit of
frustration and for large just
throughout i thought he played really
really well so he
moves on the semifinals and well on
behalf of us oman i've had a pleasure
with you it's been great to
see so many people here rooting on the
players and they'll have to wait until
tuesday
for more from the i'm not gm speeches
championship but they can enjoy their
sunday the super bowl's ahead
you're gonna watch uh i am gonna be
watching uh
i'm gonna probably go and and host a uh
a little
you know hype couple hour preview show
uh you know on the chest for all channel
real quick but then
you know i i do have to end because i
can't can't be missing the super bowl as
a as a north american robert it's just
it's a must watch well who do you got
winning uh it's not about who i got
winning it's who i bet on to win
but i i i'm cheering for i'm dreaming
for brady in the box
okay well i'm rooney from homes of the
chief so where
maybe partners for this co-commentary
gigs but now we're
enemies when it comes to our rooting
interests but iman thanks so much again
for
having this call with me today and to
everybody watching please have a good
rest of your day stay safe and be well